Und das war's für heute.
Bekannte Sounds, die zumindest für die Fans dieser Sendung in jedem Monatsende er tönen. Die wissen schon genau, was jetzt kommt. Jetzt kommt das Chaos Radio der Blue Moon mit dem Chaos Computer Club. Heute zu Gast Frank Rieger. Guten Abend. Andreas Bog und der Typ, dessen Namen ich händlicherweise nicht vergessen habe, der Björn. Björn oder Björn heißt?
Hallo, Björn Heller.
Björn Heller war's. Guten Abend. Ihr seid heute hier, um etwas über Digitalfunk zu erzählen.
Genau. Digitalfunk ist so ein toller neuer Trend, der so seit ungefähr 15 Jahren akut wird. Es geht darum, dass früher als Radio erfunden wurde, wurden die Ausstrahlung auf analogen Wege verbreitet. Also ein Wert, wie er als Ton zu hören ist, wurde genauso auf eine Radiowelle moduliert. Und heutzutage ist natürlich alles digital. Also kann man sich so ungefähr vorstellen, wie den Unterschied zwischen einer Vinylplatte, wo halt so eine Nadel hin und her wackelt und daraus einen Ton macht und einer CD, wo lauter so Bits drauf sind. Und diese Bits sind dann die Musik, die halt erst wieder umgesetzt werden müssen. Und im Äther ist mittlerweile doch der digitale Trend nicht mehr aufzuhalten. Und darüber wollen wir heute ein bisschen reden. Wir fangen an mit einer kleinen Einführung. Was ist eigentlich Digitalfunk? Wie funktioniert das so ungefähr? Und wollen dann mal ein bisschen darüber reden, ja wie kann man damit Spaß haben? Wie sind so die Erfahrungen damit und solche Dinge?
Jetzt ist jetzt Digitalfunk beschränkt sozusagen auf dieses wirklich Funken, also wie man das halt kennt, irgendwie TKKG, die fünf Freunde, die irgendwie ihre Handfunkgeräte an den Hals nehmen, wo das Digitalfunk dann noch mehr?
Nein, Digitalfunk ist ja ein sehr weiter Begriff so. Also wir haben heute zum Beispiel DVB-T, worüber wir unser Fernsehen terrestrisch empfangen. Es gibt auch Bestrebungen, das gute alte UKW-Radio durch digitales Radio zu ersetzen, das ist zum Glück noch ein bisschen hin. Der Polizeifunk wird digital, der Feuerwehrfunk wird digital. Die ganzen Mobilfunk-Telefone, die wir so haben, also GSM und UMTS und die ganzen Dinge, sind schon alle digital. Nach dem C-Netz war halt so der Cut, danach wurde es halt alles digital. Sie sind halt umgeben von digitalen Sendeverfahren und die meisten Leute wissen erstaunlich wenig darüber.
Okay, ich bin jetzt gerade überrascht geworden, weil du meintest so, Radio ist noch nicht digital und zum Glück. Das ist warum?
Naja, also eines der Probleme mit so digitalen Verfahren ist, dass man dann natürlich im ersten Mal spezielle Empfangstechnik braucht und das halt so seine gewissen Probleme hat. Und der Hauptgrund, warum Radio noch nicht digital ist, das sind die ganzen vielen Autoradios und da hat niemand Lust, irgendwie all diese Autoradios umzubauen. Bei Fernsehen haben sie es halt gemacht, um halt eine kleine Kiste dazustellen kann. Also diese DVB-T-Kiste, die also Leute, die noch ihr Fernsehen aus einer Antenne bekommen, also nicht aus einem Kabel oder aus einem Satelliten, die empfangen ihr Fernsehen seit zwei Jahren, drei Jahren, zwei Jahren digital über das digitale Videobroadcasting DVB-T terrestrisch. Das sind also diese kleinen Boxen, die man sich da so draufstellt und wo dann plötzlich, wenn der Empfang schlecht ist, rauscht es nicht mehr, sondern dann sind da so Klötzchen, dann weiß man, dass es digital ist.
Das passiert mit Volleyball oder Fußballspielen, wenn man aufsteht und das Handy anmacht.
Genau, solche Dinge. So dann gibst du halt so Störungen, die halt solche Effekte erzeugen.
Wir sollten heute vielleicht auch noch mal drüber reden, warum das ist und ob man das gegen machen kann. Weil bei WLAN gibt es ja irgendwie diese Dinge mit Chipsrollen und so was. Vielleicht gibt es auch was zum Basteln, aber können wir später machen.
Genau.
Ich würde sagen, wir schaffen jetzt erstmal die Grundlagen, weil es geht jetzt zwei Stunden und dann erklärt ihr erstmal, was jetzt eigentlich sozusagen das Grundlegende an dieser Technik ist, damit wir nachher damit Spaß haben können.
Genau. Ja, also wie schon erwähnt, der grobe Unterschied zwischen analogem Radio, wie zum Beispiel Montag noch so der Polizeifunk und der Taxifunk und unser UKW Radio ist und digitalem Funk ist genau derselbe wie zwischen der Vinylplatte und einer CD. Auf der CD sind die Daten digital gespeichert und bei digitalem Radio werden die Daten halt auch als Bits gesendet. Und die interessante Frage ist nun, wie bekommen wir die Bits fehlerfrei vom Sender zum Empfänger? So die einfachsten Verfahren, da nimmt man halt einfach eine hohe Frequenz und eine tiefe Frequenz. Das ist so genannte FSK, das heißt, das macht düüt und düüt.
Moment, also die tiefe Frequenz ist eine 0 und eine hohe D1 oder umgedreht. Aber sozusagen einfach zwei Töne, die sich sehr deutlich voneinander unterscheiden.
Genau.
Wo das Gerät auch sagen kann, okay, das war tief und das okay.
Genau, also wie wir es zum Beispiel bei so Modem haben. Wir haben es ja in unserem Trailer da, haben wir diese...
Sollen wir noch ein bisschen Modem machen?
Genau, machen wir ein bisschen Modem. Genau, und hier hören wir gerade eine ziemlich typische Signalisierung, wo wir halt hohe und tiefe Töne dabei haben, die Nullen und Einsen signalisieren. Am Anfang waren halt diese Ditut, Ditut, Ditut, Ditut. Das ist die Telefonnummer. Dann haben wir einen Synchronisationston, dieses Düüt. Und dann haben wir den, dieses... Da haben wir hohe und tiefe Töne in schneller Folge und die hohen Töne sind eine Null und die tiefen Töne sind eine Eins oder umgekehrt. So, das ist halt das einfachste Verfahren, mit dem man solche digitalen Funkdaten übertragen kann. Und da gibt es halt natürlich noch eine Menge mehr. Das sind die sogenannten Modulationsverfahren. Da kann Andreas vielleicht noch ein bisschen was zu erzählen.
Vielleicht sollten wir uns den Ton gleich nochmal anhören, den wir eben hatten, nochmal zum Hinhören. Also achtet mal drauf, am Anfang sind diese sogenannten Touchtones, diese Telefonwahltöne, die Leute, die noch Telefon aus dem Vorhandyzeitalter vielleicht noch kennen. Da sind immer, ist im Prinzip ein ähnliches Verfahren. Da gibt es auch tiefe und hohe Töne, aber nicht bloß zwei, sondern vier Stufen. Genau, DTMF. Immer zwei Töne gleichzeitig. Dann kommt einmal ein Freizeichen, da nimmt die andere Seite ab. Also wir sind ja beim Telefon, aber das Prinzip ist eigentlich dasselbe wie beim Radio, also wie beim Digitalfunk. Danach kommt erstmal ein Ton. Das ist sozusagen die Synchronisation, wo die andere Seite dann mal gucken kann. Aha, ich habe den Ton erkannt, es geht gleich los. Und dann macht es so... Das sind die eigentlichen Einsen und Nullen im Modemverfahren. Hören wir noch mal rein.
Hören wir noch mal rein.
Genau, hier haben wir die Einsen und Nullen. Damit wir mal so ein bisschen so ein Gefühl dafür bekommen.
Also ich möchte noch mal zusammenfassen, es ist also so, beim Modem ist es ja so, quasi ein Telefon ruft das andere an und dann werden diese Signale ausgetauscht. Beim Digitalfunk funktioniert das genauso, nur dass es halt über ein Ether geht, also quasi von gradlos.
Genau, also zum Beispiel bei DVBT, beim Fernsehen, sendet halt der Sender die ganze Zeit und der Empfänger empfängt die ganze Zeit und ist der Job des Empfängers klarzukommen. Also das heißt, der muss halt irgendwie sich auf dieses Signal einstellen und dabei eine Möglichkeit finden, zu wissen, wo jetzt Anfang und Ende ist und diese ganzen Dinge. Deswegen gibt es immer so genannte Synchronisations-Bits, bzw. Synchronisationssignal, das Signal ist in der Regel in Blöcke aufgeteilt. Und wenn so ein Empfänger sich später zuschaltet, dann kann er spätestens am Beginn des nächsten Blocks kommt er wieder klar. Dann kriegt er so ein, hier geht's los und ab hier fangen wir irgendwie mit einer zum Beispiel mit einer Folge von Null Bits an, dann weiß der Empfänger, aha, da sind jetzt ganz viele Nullen, sieht aus wie so ein Blockanfang und dann kommt danach Daten in einen vordefinierten Format.
Okay, das heißt immer zwischendurch wird sozusagen Signal geschickt, was dem Empfänger sagt, hier, da kannst du wieder reinkommen. Dazu zwei Fragen. Das erste ist sozusagen, man kennt es ja vom DVB-T, wenn da Störbild ist, ist das genau so was, aus dem Tritt kommen?
Naja, das kann mehrere Gründe haben, aber der einfachste Grund ist, dass deine Empfangsfeldstärke nicht ausreicht, also dass dein Empfänger den Sender nicht gut genug hören kann, de facto. Und der Effekt ist dann, dass er nicht alle Blöcke fehlerfrei mitbekommt und dann versucht er sich da irgendwas auszudenken. Dann hast du halt diese Klötzchen. Dann kommen halt nicht genug Daten an für diesen Bildausschnitt, den du da sehen möchtest. Und dann ist statt dem Fußballer halt dein grünes Klötzchen.
Okay, er denkt sich halt irgendwas aus, um das irgendwie zu faken.
Das ist halt so eines der Charakteristiken, der klare Unterschied zwischen analogen und digitalen Senderverfahren. Bei analogen Verfahren rauscht es halt, wird leiser, ist so noch so halb zu verstehen. Und bei digitalen Verfahren ist meistens irgendwann einfach Schluss.
Okay, also es gibt entweder angekommen oder Fehler.
Genau. Oder Fähre quasi.
Ja, es gibt eigentlich auch noch sowas dazwischen, aber dieses sowas dazwischen wird in der Regel durch eine sogenannte Forward Error Correction aufgefangen. Was bedeutet zu jedem Bit, also wenn ich dir drei Bits schicke, schicke ich dir noch ein Viertes dazu und sage beispielsweise naja, die Summe der Bits ist gerade oder die Summe der Bits ist ungerade. Und wenn dann eins der Bits untergeht, kannst du überlegen, aha, die Summe muss gerade sein und das Erste und das Dritte ist eine Eins, da muss das Zweite eine Null sein. Das ist Forward Error Correction.
Also man schickt halt mehr Daten als man braucht und kann sich dann mit so ein paar cleveren Algorithmen ausrechnen, welches von den Bits umgekippt ist und offenbar falsch war und wie es hätte sein müssen. Das ist ungefähr so als wenn du im Extremfall schickst halt alle Daten doppelt, dann verbrauchst du dann natürlich sehr viel mehr Bandbreite als du irgendwie hast. Als wenn du halt irgendwie über deine DSL-Leitung alle Daten doppelt schickst oder runter lädst nur um sicher zu sein, dass kein Fehler drin ist. Und bei den Funkprotokollen ist das halt sehr üblich. Also typischerweise hat man sowas wie 7 bis 20 Prozent der Daten werden. Redundant ist der Fachbegriff dafür geschickt, damit halt Fehlerdaten korrigiert werden können.
Darf ich ein kleines Bild bemühen? Bitte. Ich stelle mir gerade vor, quasi Gangster-Film, Riesengeldkoffer und drin liegt der Umflag, wo auch noch drin steht, wie viel Geld drin war.
Genau.
Der Koffer ist aber leer.
Dann ist doof.
Dann weiß ich also, okay, irgendwas ist schief gelaufen, aber wenn es so richtig schief gelaufen ist, weiß ich nicht mehr was. Genau. Aber wenn genau 10 Euro fehlen, könnte ich denken, oh, es ist vielleicht dieser Schein.
Zum Beispiel. Und so ähnlich funktioniert es halt bei all diesen ganzen digitalen Sendeverfahren, dass man versucht, die Unzulänglichkeiten des Ethers, also da ist Rauschen und Signal wird reflektiert und dann regnet es auch mal oder es ist ein nasser Wald dazwischen oder ähnliche Dinge.
Oder die Sonne scheint.
Oh, die Sonne scheint, ja. Oder die Luftfeuchtigkeit ist hoch. Die versucht man damit zu kompensieren, dass man sich sehr clevere Methoden ausdenkt. Zum einen die Art und Weise, wie man die Bits codiert, also das, was wir mit den hohen Tiefentönen hatten. Da gibt es halt noch unglaublich viele clevere Verfahren, Modulationsverfahren, die wir später vielleicht noch ein bisschen im Detail beleuchten.
Sollen wir vielleicht einfach gleich die Wichtigsten durchgehen?
Ja, können wir machen. Genau.
Oder soll ich vielleicht mal Niklas rannehmen? Der will nämlich fragen, warum es bestimmt viele Töne bei bestimmten Verfahren gibt. Vielleicht haben wir es ja gerade damit zusammen. Guten Abend, Niklas. Sag mal, deine Frage ist?
Genau, meine Frage wäre, warum gilt es bei der Telefonübertragung zum Beispiel nur zwei bzw. vier Töne, wie ihr erwähnt habt, und nicht zum Beispiel 512 Töne, die dann einen bestimmten Algorithmus haben und dann zu höheren Datenübertragungen führen könnten?
Sowas gibt es auch, das nennt sich dann FDM. Frequency Division Multiplex. Also beim Telefon ist es einfach so, die mussten halt 0 bis 9 abbilden und dann noch Stern und Raute und dann waren sie bei 12 und dann haben sie sich gedacht, naja, 4 reichen. Und du kannst aber natürlich auch 512 verschiedene Töne nehmen und dann kannst du mehr Daten übertragen. Das Ganze hat natürlich Grenzen. Und zwar liegen die Grenzen darin, dass zum Beispiel über Telefon nur eine gewisse, man hat das Bandbreite übertragen kann. Telefon klingt halt nach Telefon, sind ein bisschen dumpf, sind keine Höhen drin. Geht halt von 0 bis 3 Kilohertz ungefähr oder von 100 Hertz bis 3 Kilohertz. Und da passt halt nur endlich viel rein. Also du kannst dann irgendwann diese verschiedenen Töne nicht mehr auseinanderhalten. Das ist so, die Idee ist im Grunde genommen gut. Das wird bei verschiedensten Verfahren gemacht, also bei digital Fernsehen zum Beispiel, bei auch bei der DRM Kurzwelle, da kannst du vielleicht gleich noch was dazu erzählen, bei DSL Modems übrigens auch. Das hat auch große Vorteile und was man dann nämlich machen kann, manchmal hat man ja Störungen auf bestimmten Frequenzen, während Tinnitus hat, kennt das, auf einem Ton hört man halt nichts.
Das hab ich jetzt leider nicht vorbereitet zum Einspielen.
Aber kann man sich sicherlich vorstellen. Und auf der Frequenz geht halt nichts. Sowas gibt es auch mit Leitung, sowas gibt es auch mit Funkverbindung. Und wenn man dann diese 512 Töne gleichzeitig hat, oder wieviel auch immer, kann man vorher mal messen, welche denn gut sind und welche schlecht. Man kann auch wieder anfangen, seine Bits auf mehrere Frequenzen zu verteilen, wenn eine gestört wird, das ist halt wieder egal.
Also mehr ist besser? Was ist denn gerade sozusagen im Moment das Praktische, was verwendet wird? Habt ihr eine Hausnummer?
Es hängt halt sehr von dem Kanal ab, den du hast. Also je breiter dein Kanal ist, so Telefon halt, mit den 3 Kilohertz, da machen sie glaube ich maximal 256 momentan.
Ich glaube über so einen echten Audio-Kanal gehen tatsächlich nur so was wie 64 Kilo bit drüber. Aber über die Telefonleitungen gehen über kurze Distanzen wesentlich mehr, als sie je gedacht hätten. Da sind sie mittlerweile bei 130 Mbit, 150, 200 Mbit teilweise über normalen Telefondraht. Das sind dann tausende von Frequenzen, auf denen gleichzeitig gesendet wird.
Also wir sehen schon so die Technologien, die halt verwendet werden um DSL zu machen und die die verwendet werden um Digitalfunk zu machen sind im Kern dieselben. Es hat dieselben mathematischen Verfahren, dieselben Übertragungs- und Modulationsverfahren. Und die werden halt jeweils immer angepasst an den Zweck. Also wenn man halt zum Beispiel so eine Telefonleitung hat, da steigt halt die die Häufigkeit von Störungen mit der Länge der Leitung. Bei Funkverfahren ist es halt ähnlich, je weiter man funkt, zum Beispiel wenn man Kurzwelle funkt, braucht man eine schmalere Bandbreite und wesentlich mehr Störungen. Und man passt dann dieses Verfahren, also die Modulationsverfahren, die man verwendet, daran an, wie gut oder schlecht der Kanal ist, den man zur Verfügung hat. Danach wählt man halt aus zum Beispiel, wie viele Töne man auf diesen Kanal drauf tut.
Was jetzt zum Beispiel mich auch eine ganz interessante Sache wäre meiner Meinung nach, wenn man zum Beispiel auf einer um sich in Rookmiete, zum Beispiel mit 100 Mbit, da ein Dictionary drauflegt, dass der und der Ton zusammen 00101 blablabla ergibt. Und das halt in einer langen Reihenfolge, dass der halt nur diese einzelnen Buchstaben oder was auch immer überschickt in diesen kurzen Flipgrenzen und dann der Fullspeed erreicht werden könnte.
Ich möchte die anwesenden Herren bitten, die Frage nochmal so zu übersetzen. Ich verstehe oder geht es euch so wie mir?
Ich versuch's mal. Ich glaube du hast auch wieder etwas erfunden, was es schon länger gibt und das ist die Übertragung von mehreren Bits gleichzeitig. Also man kann, wenn man nicht zwei Töne hat so, sondern man hat, dann kann man ja, hat man ja vier verschiedene Zustände. Das heißt mit jedem Signal kann man zwei Bits übertragen, weil mit zwei Bits kann man vier Zustände annehmen. Man redet von einem Symbol. Also ein Symbol ist ein Ton auf vier verschiedenen Frequenzen. Jetzt in meinem Beispiel und der überträgt zwei Bits. Ich glaube, das ist ungefähr das, was du meintest, oder?
Naja, nicht ganz. Also wenn ich jetzt den einen Ton hab, den hohen Ton zum Beispiel, ergibt das 0, 0 oder eine 0. Und wenn ich jetzt einen siebenstelligen Code rüberschicken würde über die Leitung halt, und der wird dann in das Dictionary gucken und wissen, aha, der siebenstellige Code ist nach meiner Übersetzung 400 oder 500 Zeichen lang, dann wäre...
Also was du damit tust, ist, du vermischst halt die Kompression und die Symboltabellen.
Genau, ich kompumiere.
Genau, also sowas Ähnliches findet tatsächlich statt, also dass die Symboltabellen nach Häufigkeit der Bitmuster sortiert werden. Also kann man sich ungefähr so vorstellen, man nimmt sich ein Wetterbuch und sagt, okay, diese Worte, die ich hier so verwende, die sind häufiger als andere. Also und zum Beispiel kommt es ja häufig vor. Also kürzen wir halt mal und durch ein kürzeres Symbol ab und vereinbaren es einfach so. Also der Sender weiß, dass und irgendwie 001 ist und der Empfänger weiß, dass und 001 ist und können dadurch eine Kompression erreichen. Aber das findet tatsächlich von einer anderen Ebene statt.
Lassen wir Morse Code als digital durchgehen?
Morse Code war meines Erachtens das erste digitale Übertragungsverfahren. Also genau das hier.
Dann schannt ihr über uns, dass wir es noch nicht erwähnt haben. Weil da passiert genau dasselbe. Da sind auch die verschiedenen Buchstaben mit verschiedenen Tonfolgen kodiert. Und die Häufigen mit kurzen und die Seltenen mit langen. Also so ein E ist zum Beispiel so ein BIP. Und ein S ist BIBIBIB. Und je seltener der Buchstabe, desto länger die Sequenz.
Also ich komme jetzt nicht mehr ganz hinterher, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Das heißt also, was er gefragt hat, geht nicht wirklich?
Also ich habe noch nicht ganz verstanden, was der Zweck davon sein sollte. Es gibt sozusagen diverse Dinge da draußen, die so ähnlich klingen, die schon mal jemand erfunden hat.
Genau, also viele von diesen Dingen kann man sich halt auch so logisch erschließen. Jetzt haben wir gerade noch ein Beispiel von Morse, hoffe ich mal.
Okay, das ist was? Ja, aber was für Morse Code?
Das ist, überlassen wir unseren Lesern.
Mal gucken, ob ein Hörer es weiß. Der erste, der es weiß und anruft, gewinnt...
Einen Anruf. Genau, da haben wir noch ein paar Rätsel von. Also wer irgendwie gerade sein Demolation Software im Startup Event spielt ja noch ein paar mehr.
Spielen wir es nochmal ein, jetzt zum Mitschreiben?
Genau, mach mal die ein bisschen schneller.
Okay, wenn ihr euch gerade fragt, was passiert zur Hölle hier? Das ist das Chaos Radio. Wir reden heute über Digitalfunk. Das heißt Informationen in Bits und Bytes über die Luft übertragen. Und das geht oder ist als er hat als erstes funktioniert mit Morso Code. Wenn ihr rausgefunden habt, was da gerade gemorst wurde, könnt ihr anrufen und das sagen. Dann gewinnt ihr einen Anruf.
Also die Amateur Funka unter euch, die werden das sicherlich kennen. Und derjenige, der anruft, würde von mir noch direkt dazu als Gimmick eine Mate bekommen.
Muss man das eigentlich noch erklären, was Mate ist?
Wird nur die Mate nicht für die späteren, härteren Modulationsverfahren nehmen.
Entschuldigung. Wir waren glaube ich mitten drin stehen geblieben.
Genau. Ich wollte Niklas jetzt fragen, ob wir uns darauf einlegen können, dass wir die Frage wahrscheinlich nicht erschöpfend beantworten können.
Also dies denke ich mir noch ziemlich weitreichend.
Alles klar.
Und zu guter Letzt würde ich noch fragen, ob ich bitte den Gerhard grüßen könnte.
So, weiter geht's.
So, genau, wir waren nämlich stehen geblieben beim Modulationsverfahren, glaube ich. Eine ganz wichtige ist die Amplitudenmodulation.
Warte mal, also für den Fall, dass irgendjemand da draußen genauso raus ist wie ich, kannst du mal kurz sagen, Modulationsverfahren war was?
Das ist die Töne, die man macht, damit du weißt, was Nullen und Einsen sind.
Okay.
Das nennt sich Modulation.
Das heißt, wo wir im einfachsten Fall zwei von haben.
Genau.
Und das Gegenteil oder es gibt noch einen noch einfachen Fall, das wir eben gehört haben, ist ja Morse Code. Und da ist halt dieses Piep, das ist entweder da und es ist nicht da. Das heißt, man kann sagen, es ist einmal laut, es ist einmal leise. Und auch so kann man Informationen übertragen, die man sagt, wenn es leise pieps, ist es eine Null. Wenn es laut pieps, ist es eine Eins. Wenn es gar nichts pieps, dann empfängt man gerade nichts.
Okay.
Und bei Morse ist es halt so, dass halt kurze und lange Piepse, die daraus werden halt die Zeichen zusammengesetzt. Und der Morse Code ist halt das erste Beispiel von so einem komprimierenden Code. Da ist halt so, dass man je häufiger der Buchstabe benutzt wird, desto weniger Bibs und Blobs braucht man.
Das E hat irgendwie...
Hat nur einen.
Okay.
Also das ist so, dass die... Also war ganz einfach, die Leute haben das halt benutzt, um zu funken bzw. zu telegrafieren. Und das wurde halt tatsächlich noch aus der Zeit mit Taste gemacht, also mit Kurztaste drücken und lange Taste drücken. Und da möchte man natürlich die Anzahl der Tastendrücke, schon allein damit man keine Sehnscheine anzunommen kommt, möchte man die Anzahl der Tastendrücke limitieren. Und deswegen verwendet man halt so eine komprimierenden Verfahren. Also ähnlich ist es halt, also wird da zumindest behauptet, wurden ja diese Schreibmaschinentastaturen optimiert, also Dvorak und so, die halt auch die Tasten, die häufiger benutzt wurden, an bequemere Stellen gelegt haben. So, so eine Sachen finden halt immer wieder auch, also gerade bei so einem Funkverfahren statt.
Okay, wir wissen also jetzt schon nach einer halben Stunde, wie ich mal bemerken muss. Wir wissen jetzt schon, es gibt also Digitalfunk, der funktioniert so, dass man möglichst geschickt und möglichst störungsfreie Signale, also Bits und Bytes quasi, wie eine Internetleitung über die Luft schickt. Und wir waren jetzt bei Morsiging geblieben, das ist ja schon eine Weile her.
Ja, also war das älteste Funkverfahren überhaupt, da war es halt so, dass man noch keine, also keine Möglichkeit hat, Sprache zu übertragen, sondern man konnte halt eigentlich nur den Sender an und aus machen. Und so die Sender, die sie da verwendet haben, hatten dann so schöne Bezeichnungen wie ein Löschfunken Sender. Das war halt ein Gerät, was halt irgendwie so, also...
Der hat auch nicht auf einer spezifischen Frequenz gesendet, der hat einfach bloß so HF-Müll erzeugt.
Also der hat halt einfach im Radiospektrum so Pratz gemacht.
Das ist so das Knacken, was man teilweise hört, wenn man irgendwie sein Netzteil in die Steckdose steckt.
Also sprichst das sagen, stellt euch vor, ihr macht euer Radio an und egal, welche Frequenz ihr anmacht, es ist überall dasselbe. So, wir wollen jetzt aber mal vorspulen, weil Digitalfunk in den Außennachrichten ist ja der, dass man gehört hat, ja, die Berliner Polizei soll jetzt mal Digitalfunk bekommen. Ach nee, doch nicht. Ach ja, doch, vielleicht doch dieses Jahr. Ach nee, vielleicht doch nicht.
Genau, also diese Digitalfunkgeschichte ist halt eine sehr lange. Momentan ist es halt so, dass Polizei und Feuerwehr und Krankenwagen und technisches Hilfswerk senden alle noch analog. Also die haben halt noch Geräte, wo, wenn man da so reinspricht, dann sind da hübsche Frequenzschwankungen, also Frequenzmodulationen auf dem Radio. Also wenn man dann so aufs Radiospektrum guckt, dann sieht man halt, mit der Sprache wackelt halt die Frequenz, auf der gesendet wird, das ist die sogenannte Frequenzmodulation. Das ist eine der Möglichkeiten. Die andere ist die sogenannte Amplitudmodulation. Da wackelt halt die Sende Stärke mit der Sprache mit. Also kann man sich so vorstellen, wie wenn man sich so ein Audiophile auf dem Bildschirm anguckt, dann sendt man auch so diese Kurve hoch und runter. Und genauso sieht dann halt auch das Signal aus. So bei dem einen, also die Frequenzmodulation wackelt halt die Sendefrequenz und bei Amplitudmodulationen wackelt die Signalstärke. Und das wird dann halt am Ende wieder dekodiert. Und die Geräte, die die Polizei da momentan verwendet, stammen halt so aus den frühen 80ern. Die sind halt mittlerweile auf dem Status angekommen, dass sie auf dem Flohmarkt gucken gehen, ob sie noch Teile kriegen. Die haben natürlich nur geplant, also eigentlich sollte Tetra ursprünglich zu S96 eingefriedert werden.
Tetra ist jetzt das Schlagwort, das sollst du sagen, ist der neue Digitale für die Polizei.
Tetra ist der neue digitale Funk, der eigentlich alle Leute, die halt im Bereich Ordnung und Sicherheit unterwegs sind, also Behörden für Ordnung und Sicherheit, BOS, sollen damit ausgestattet werden. Das ist mittlerweile ein ziemlich altes Verfahren. Das ist glaube ich von 96 oder so. Solange hat es halt gedauert, bis die...
Hey, es ist alt. Es ist Zeit, das mal bei uns einführen.
Na ja, es ist halt gut abgehangen. Gut abgehangen. Es ist eine wohlabgehangene, gut erforschte Technologie.
Okay, ich würde jetzt gerne Folgendes machen. Wir haben jetzt quasi die Basis, also wir wissen, was Digitalfunk ist. Und wir wissen auch, dass nicht nur die Polizei, sondern auch Behörden damit arbeiten soll. Es soll noch eingeführt werden, aber vielleicht gibt es auch schon mal draußen. Und die Frage wäre jetzt...
Genau, hat einer von euch schon damit Erfahrungen? Ist zufällig einer von euch bei einer Behörde für Ordnung und Sicherheit oder so, die wo halt Tetra schon verwendet wird? Oder zum Beispiel bei der BVG, da wird Tetra auch schon verwendet. Hat da einer schon von Erfahrung? Ist das toll? Rocked it? Oder was sind so die Probleme? Würde uns interessieren, wie war die Nummer?
0331 70 97 110. Ich kann es auch noch mal ein schöner sagen lassen.
0331 70 97 110.
Und zwar dann, wenn ihr schon Erfahrungen gemacht habt mit dem neuen Behördenfunk, Tetra heißt das Teil, oder wenn ihr vielleicht schon geschult worden seid, es irgendwie schon mal in den Fingern gehabt hat, dann ruft jetzt an. Während ihr euch die Finger wundwählt, werden wir eine kleine Musik spielen. Die Musik ist heute in Zusammenarbeit mit dem geschätzten Publikum entstanden. Zum Beispiel im IRC-Kanal, da könnt ihr hingehen, der ist zu finden unter irc.freenote.net im Channel Chaos Radio oder auf der Wiki Seite chaosradio.de. Einfach durchklicken. Danach gibt es Nachrichten, Beleuchtung und Verkehr und dann machen wir weiter mit dem Digitalfunk.
Das hier sind Anna und Tobi und Sophie. Die drei würden gern mal zusammen tanzen gehen, aber Anna mag Rock. Tobi steht total auf Elektro und Sophie liebt Urban Beat. Das heißt, die drei können nie zusammen Party machen. Außer Samstag. Die Fritz-Club-Disco. Einfach gut tanzen auf drei Flohs. Elektro-Beats. Kein Club bietet mehr. Die Fritz-Club-Disco. Drei Flohs plus Sommergarten. Immer samstags ab 23 Uhr im Fritz-Club im Postbahnhof. Und das wird man.
Um kurz nach halb elf.
Nachrichten.
In Berlin geht die Diskussion über die geplanten Zugangsregeln zu Gymnasien weiter. Bildungssenator Zöhner hat das von ihm vorgeschlagene Losverfahren verteidigt. Zöhner sagte in der RBB-Abendschau, es gebe keine Alternative, jede andere Lösung sei schlechter. Der Bildungssenator will, dass Plätze fürs Gymnasium teilweise ausgelost werden, wenn es zu viele Bewerber gibt. Eltern und auch Schulleiter kritisieren die Pläne. Im Berliner Kanzleramt geht es gerade um die Zukunft von Opel. Bei dem Spitzentreffen sind Kanzlerin Merkel und die Minister der Länder mit Opel-Standorten dabei. Auf dem Tisch liegen die Konzepte von drei Interessenten. Dass es heute eine Entscheidung gibt, ist allerdings unwahrscheinlich. Das hat ein Regierungssprecher vorab gesagt. Aus China gibt es auch einen Interessenten, allerdings kam das Angebot für heute zu spät und wird erst in den nächsten Tagen geprüft. Die Streits in den kommunalen Kindertagesstätten gehen weiter. Nach Gesprächen mit den Arbeitgebern in Berlin erklärte die Gewerkschaft ver.di die Tarifverhandlungen für die rund 220.000 Beschäftigten für vorerst gescheitert. Der kommunale Arbeitgeberverband hatte ein Angebot zum Gesundheitsschutz vorgelegt, das sowohl ver.di als auch die GEW als nicht akzeptabel zurückwiesen. Heute beteiligten sich bundesweit rund 15.000 Beschäftigte an dem Ausstand in Kindergärten, Horten, Jugendzentren und Beratungsstellen. In Berlin hat es bei den Mathe-Prüfungen für den mittleren Schulabschluss heute erneut eine Panne gegeben. Wir im letzten Jahr kursierten wieder Prüfungsaufgaben im Internet. Allerdings waren es diesmal die falschen. Ein Sprecher vom Bildungssenat sagte, jemand habe die Aufgaben vom letzten Jahr mit einem neuen Deckblatt ans Netz gestellt. Die aktuellen Aufgaben sollen aber nicht durchgesickert sein. Wegen einer solchen Panne mussten letztes Jahr 28.000 Berliner Zehntklässer die Mathe-Prüfungen wiederholen. In Rom kämpfen gerade Europas beste Fußballklubs im Finale der Champions League gegeneinander. Manchester United gegen FC Barcelona. Zum Ende der zweiten Halbzeit steht es 2 zu 0 für Barcelona. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen, Kotsdam 12 Grad, Cottbus Frankfurt, Neurophin und Angermünde 13 Grad, Wittenberg 15 Grad und in Berlin auch 15 Grad. Am Abend gibt nur noch vereinzelt Schauer, teilweise ist ganz windig draußen. Die Temperaturen gehen weiter runter auf 11 bis 7 Grad. Morgen ist es dann ähnlich wie heute. Ein bisschen Sonne, ein bisschen Wolken und auch Regen kann immer noch runterkommen bei maximal 18 Grad. A10 südlicher Berliner Ring Richtung Dreieck Werder zwischen Ludwigsfelde Ost und Ludwigsfelde West. Da ist die rechte Spur durch einen Ziegelstein gesperrt, fast da ein bisschen auf. A10 westlicher Berliner Ring Richtung Dreieck Haveland zwischen Potsdam Nord und Spandau. Da ist die linke Spur gesperrt wegen einem defekten LKW. Dann die A13 Berlin Richtung Dresden. Bei Lübbenau, da liegen Gegenstände auf der Fahrbahn und die A24 Hamburg Richtung Berlin. Zwischen Herzsprung und Neuropin, da ist ein Pannfahrzeug auf der rechten Spur, die ist gesperrt. Ansonsten Reutz, gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 101, 5, dann Fritz in Frankfurt oder.
Die zwei Sprechstunden mit Markus Richter, Frank Rieger, Björn Heller und Andreas Bog, der gerade nicht hier ist. Was macht denn der eigentlich gerade? Kann ja wohl nicht wahr sein. Chaosradio, wie es leibt und lebt. Es geht heute um Digitalfunk eigentlich. Aber wie im Chat gerade bemerkt wurde und was ja auch eigentlich vorher so vereinbart waren, wir wollten ja noch ganz kurz was sagen zu der Sache, wo beinahe 100.000 Leute.
Genau. Falls ihr noch nicht getan habt, es gibt ja noch die Petitionen gegen die Internetzensur. Unsere heiß geliebte Familienministerin Zenzosa von der Leyen möchte ja gerne eine Zensur im Internet einführen. Dagegen gibt es eine E-Petition beim Bundestag, die die Orals irgendwo auf www.cde verlinkt, relativ weit oben. Wenn ihr da noch nicht mitgezeichnet habt, dann tut es bitte. Es geht einfach darum zu verhindern, dass in Deutschland eine Internetzensur unter dem Deckmantel des Schutzes vor Kinderpornografie eingeführt wird. Und das wollen wir doch bitte vermeiden.
Und ich möchte verzeihen, dass diese wichtige politische Debatte zu schamloser Eigenwerbung genutzt wird. Wenn euch nämlich für das Thema interessiert, das ist schon dieses Jahr zweimal im Chaosradio besprochen worden. Auf Chaosradio.de und auf Fritz.de gibt es die Podcasts dazu. Und sozusagen fast wochenaktuelle Updates gibt es am Samstag immer bei Trackback. Und damit kehren wir jetzt aber zurück zum Digitalfunk. Wir haben ja aufgerufen, es soll mal jemand anrufen, der sozusagen schon mit dem neuen Digitalfunk, was die Polizei bekommen soll, was sagen könnte, das waren noch bis jetzt keiner. Ich vermute es liegt am Spiel, am Endspiel der Champions League. Aber auch das wird ja bald vorbei sein.
Also meinst du, es gibt eine größere Wahrscheinlichkeit von Zielgruppen?
Ich...
Feuerwehrmänner, Polizeimänner, Fußball könnte ich mir vorstellen. Ich weiß nicht so genau.
Ja gut, wir sind auch ehrlich gesagt noch ein kürze kleines bisschen zu früh dran dafür.
Wait, what?
Wir haben noch eine halbe Stunde gerade erklärt, was Digitalfunk ist. Was fehlt denn noch?
Nein, was noch fehlt, ist, dass die Systeme werden halt... Also da finden gerade erst die Schulungen daraus in Stad. Die Schulungen für die Feuerwehr und die Polizei.
Ah, okay.
Also in Berlin sind glaube ich bisher 400 oder 500 Geräte im Einsatz, auch mehr so testhalber parallel zum alten analogen Funksystem. Aber vielleicht finden wir jemanden, der uns ein bisschen was erzählen kann, was denn so die Probleme mit dem alten analogen Feuerwehr beziehungsweise Polizeifunk waren. Das wäre auch tatsächlich interessant.
0331 70 97 110.
Ist genau die Nummer, die ihr anruft, wenn ihr aus dem Nähkästen plaudern wollt.
Genau. Und haben wir schon jemand? Niemand. Wahrscheinlich sind wir zu hoch gestochen. Gut, also ich erzähl noch mal ein bisschen was zu diesem Tetra. Das ist ja durchaus interessant. Also der Grund für die Einführung des digitalen Prinzipfunks ist zum einen, dass sie mehr Kanäle, also mehr Sprechkanäle haben wollten, weil man kann durch diese Kompression der Sprache, wie man sie halt aus der Musik kennt, also mp3, man kann die Musik komprimieren, dann ist weniger Platz weg. Genau dasselbe geht bei Funk halt auch. Man kann die Sprache so komprimieren, dass man sie in weniger Bits unterbekommt. Und diese weniger Bits brauchen entsprechend auch weniger Bandbreite auf dem Funk.
Und diese Erklärung wollte Sven nicht mehr hören. Entschuldigung, der hat nämlich angerufen und kann was zu analogen BOS-Funk. Ist das das, was wir wollen? Ah, sehr gut. Hallo, guten Abend Sven. Du bist einer von denen, der bei einer offiziellen Behörde arbeitet und mit dem alten Funk zu tun hat. Und der ist sozusagen, und du willst jetzt eigentlich neuen Digitalfunk?
Also Digitalfunk ist ja schön und gut, also das Hauptproblem ist einfach der Kostenfaktor. Das ist, was ich so sehe, ja, da wird Geld rausgeschmissen. Also ist meine Meinung dazu. Klar, es gibt Vorteile und es gibt auch Nachteile.
Wieso meinst du, dass da Geld rausgeschmissen wird?
Also eigentlich der Hauptgrund, warum man Digitalfunk einführen möchte, ist ja der Abhörsicherung. Wenn ich das jetzt mal so sagen darf. Es gibt da viele schwarze Schafe, die den BOS-Funk so mithören und auch ein bisschen stören darüber.
Und um vor denen geschützt zu sein.
Ja genau.
Und meinst du, ist das tatsächlich der wesentliche Grund, dass das bei euch so kommuniziert wird, dass das der Grund ist oder werden da auch noch andere Dinge angeführt?
Also das ist der Hauptgrund, was jetzt bei uns, also wir hatten jetzt einen Schulungstag bisher, wo mal kurz so ein Gerät vorgeführt worden ist. Und ja, vom Weiten durften wir uns das mal angucken, aber mehr auch im Moment da noch nicht.
Das heißt, ihr durftet da auch noch nicht mit rumspielen, um mal zu gucken, wie es sich so bedient oder so?
Nee, durften wir leider auch noch nicht.
Ok, und bist du bei einer Polizei oder bei einer Feuerwehrbehörde?
Ok, darf ich kurz auch was fragen? Ich hab mir kurz in so einem Feuerwehrbüchlein gelesen, was das neue Digitalfunk alles kann und das lasse ich für mich so, das ist ja quasi fast wie ein Handy. Also du kannst irgendwie Kurznachrichten verschicken, du kannst ja quasi verschiedene Nummer anrufen. Das ist doch eigentlich ziemlich geil oder nicht?
Ja, natürlich. Ich sage nicht, dass es schwachsinnig ist, aber für mich ist es einfach nur Geld zum Fenster raus schmeißen.
Das heißt, du bist mit dem alten System total zufrieden?
Ja, nicht total zufrieden. Also die Zuverlässigkeit des alten Systems ist ja, lassen wir mal da hingestellt, gerade bei schlechten Witter oder wenn man mal irgendwo am Randgebiet ist, ist es schon problematisch.
Also da habt ihr tatsächlich auch echte Probleme, ja?
Ja, da haben wir Probleme.
Und dann nehmt ihr einfach wieder das Mobiltelefon, wenn es gar nicht anders geht oder wie?
Da gehen wir wieder über Draht, genau.
Okay, das finde ich immer so schön. Das Überdraht bedeutet heutzutage ja nicht ein drahtgebundenes Telefon, sondern ein Mobiltelefon. Okay, und wie sieht das bei euch so aus? Der Kostenfaktor, werden dafür andere Sachen zurückgestellt? Also kriegt ihr dann irgendwie keine neuen Kettensägen deswegen, weil ihr neue Funkgeräte kriegt? Oder wie muss man sich das vorstellen?
Nö, also das nicht, aber über den Etat genauer wissen wir halt auch nicht. Also da wird halt immer gemunkelt und gemunkelt. Das ist ja auch so eine Frage, wo nimmt man das Geld jetzt her? Wenn man sich jetzt mal überlegt, so ein Funkgerät kostet 1000 Euro, also ein bisschen mehr als 1000 Euro.
Und die müssen halt auch irgendwo herkommen.
Die müssen ja auch irgendwo herkommen.
Wie viel mehr ist das als die alten Kosten?
Die alten, soweit ich informiert bin, kosten um die 200 bis 300.
Kann man die überhaupt noch kaufen? Ich sehe ja immer diese Dinge aus den 70ern, mit denen man im Zweifelsfall auch werfen kann, wenn man sich verteidigen lässt. Wenn ich das mit mir rumschleppen würde und in der anderen Tasche habe ich so ein modernes Mobiltelefon, würde ich mir schon ein bisschen verschaukelt vorkommen, muss ich sagen.
Ja, es gibt auch viele Kollegen, die schaffen sich halt bessere Funkgeräte privat an. Das sieht man ja auch nicht gerne. Weil? Ja, weil man damit halt auch missbräuchlich arbeiten kann.
Inwiefern? Kann man sozusagen die Kollegen damit unsinnanstellen oder sind die leichter auszunutzen?
Die können einmal selber damit umgehen und man kann auch andere Kanäle, für die man gar nicht irgendwo zugelassen ist.
Ja verstehe, die holen sich dann halt einfach Amateurfunkgeräte und benutzen die auf den vorgesehenen Kanälen.
Aber es gibt ja so viele im Internet, Kusinen, so viele Sachen herum, wie man sich BOS, also Amateurfunkgeräte umbauen kann zu BOS.
Das heißt da gibt es offensichtlich schon einen deutlichen Bedarf. Okay, das war ja doch durchaus sehr interessant. Und gibt es irgendwie einen Zeitplan, den sie euch gesagt haben, wann ihr das Zeug bekommen werdet?
Denke ich eher nicht.
Also sieht man das?
Das ist meine Meinung. Nein.
Okay, verstehe.
Ich würde noch interessieren, wie sie versucht haben euch so die Features dieses neuen Standards zu verkaufen. Also haben sie euch da gezeigt, wie toll das ist so mit den SMS verschicken, irgendwie Daten Kanal für Daten übertragen zum Laptop etc.
oder? Wie gesagt, wir hatten erst eine Schulung, also das ist eine Schulung, da wurde uns mal kurz so ein Gerät gezeigt und halt die Vorteile des neuen Funks aufgezeigt.
Also ich habe noch eine gute Nachricht. Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass diese neuen Geräte funktionieren, ist relativ hoch, weil wenn meine Information stimmt, haben sie in Berlin diese Nokia-Geräte gekauft und die basieren auf die S40-Reihe von Nokia. Das sind die 6310, wer sich erinnert, das war das beste Telefon, was Nokia je gebaut hat. Also wenigstens ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit groß, dass es geht hinterher.
Warte mal, das neue Funkgerät digital ist quasi ein umgebautes altes Telefon?
Ja, na also es beruht auf derselben Software und hat dieselbe Benutzerinterferenz. Also wer so ein altes Nokia in der Hand hatte, wird mit so einem Funkgerät im wesentlichen Grupp umgehen können.
Ist das von der Bedienung her dann genauso auch tatsächlich, dass man das wie ein Telefon hat und nicht mehr den Unterschied erkennt?
Also ich hab bisher nur Manuals im Web gesehen und die waren halt, das Ding ist halt ganz schön groß. Also du verwechselst es nicht mit deinem Telefon. Also die Gefahr besteht nicht, aber du kannst halt die selben Shortcuts benutzen zum Beispiel für...
Nee, aber ich mein, ist es dann quasi auch tatsächlich so, dass man Nummern anrufen kann?
Nee, das ist ja, Tetra ist ja ein ziemlich komplexes System. Können wir vielleicht noch mal kurz ein bisschen weiter zu sagen, wie es funktioniert. Das ist ein sogenanntes Bündelfunksystem. Das heißt, es funktioniert so ähnlich wie ein normales Mobilfunksystem. Das heißt, man hat sogenannte Zellen, da stehen halt Massen rum mit Antennen und zu denen nimmt dein Telefon Kontakt auf.
Ist das neu jetzt beim digitalen Funk? Das war bei dem alten nicht.
Genau, bei dem alten ist es so, dass es nur sogenannte Repeater gab, die halt das Signal wieder abgestrahlt haben. Und jetzt mit diesem Bündelfunk funktioniert es halt, also Tetra ist ein Bündelfunksystem, funktioniert es halt über diese Zellen. Das heißt also dein Ruf geht halt erstmal zu einer Zelle und von der Zelle dann zu dem Zielfunkgerät, wo du hin möchtest. Und das kann auch in einer ganz anderen Zelle sein.
Also wie beim normalen Handy sozusagen.
Genau, das wird halt vermittelt. Der Unterschied ist halt nur, dass das halt nicht ein Anruf ist, sondern du halt auf eine Taste drückst und dann halt der Ruf aufgebaut wird.
Wobei dann halt noch die ganzen Vorteile von herkömmlichen Funkgeräten natürlich auch implementiert sind. Also man hat dann irgendwie auch die Möglichkeit, so direkt Ruf zu machen von Handy oder Funkgerät, besser gesagt zu Funkgerät. Oder halt auch ein Funkgerät, wenn man jetzt irgendwie abgelegene Bergregionen hat irgendwie und da ist halt so ein Polizeiauto, das stellt sich halt auf einen hochgelegenen Berg. Und das spielt dann irgendwie Relais wie konventionell auch heutzutage möglich. Und leitet für die anderen Funkgerätinnen die Gespräche über weitere Distanzen weiter.
Also so weit die Theorie zumindest.
Wir haben jetzt noch Peter in der Leitung. Der hat so ein Ding anscheinend schon mal in den Fingern gehabt. Hallo Peter, ein neues oder ein altes?
Ja, eins von diesen, wie ihr gesagt habt, die nach Not herriechen.
Da sind die Leute hier glaube ich ganz begierig drauf, dass du mal erzählst, was du damit erfahren hast.
Ja, ich hatte das Gerät vor, jetzt muss ich mal lügen, 2, 5, 3 Jahren in den Fingern bei einem passenden Funklehrgang.
Dein Telefon ist ein bisschen abgehackt. Kannst du den Empfang verbessern, indem du ans Fenster gehst oder so?
Der klassische Digitaleffekt?
Ja, genau.
Digitalfunkfehler am praktischen Beispiel.
Jetzt eine Nummer besser? Na gut, ich hatte vor 2, 5, 3 Jahren so ein Gerät mal in den Fingern, ging auch, war ein Ausbilderlehrgang und da haben sie uns dann unter Androhung von irgendwas, dass ja keine Bilder von den Geräten auftauchen, haben so ein paar Geräte, die damals in Stuttgart in Betrieb waren, das war damals die erste Referenzplattform so für Deutschland, in die Finger gegeben zum Bespielen und erste Idee war natürlich auch sieht nach Nokia aus, riecht nach Nokia, Tastensperre war natürlich irgendwie einmal Mitte, einmal links unten. Er ist auf den Dingern ja nicht gerade zu Hause gefühlt, aber man kannte es halt irgendwo.
Und hast du zu sagen, hast du nur das das Totgerät in den Händen gehabt oder konntest du tatsächlich auch mit funken? Okay, Peter, es tut mir leid das sagen zu müssen und ich hätte echt gerne deine Geschichte gehört, aber die Verbindung ist wirklich totale Grutze. Alles klar, das ist eine gute Idee. 0331 70 97 110 ist die Nummer, die Peter dazu anruft, die ihr auch anrufen könnt, wenn ihr was zum Digitalfunk fragen oder erzählen wollt.
Genau, also das was wir gerade gehört haben, ist der sogenannte Grenzreichweiteffekt. Das heißt also das Signal reißt dann halt ab, es wird dann nicht rauschiger oder schlechter, sondern es wird halt erstmal so blockiger. Das heißt, es kommt nicht mehr jeder Datenblock durch. Und dann ist halt ganz weg.
Okay, so hört sich Digitalfunk an, wenn er nicht funktioniert. Sven, du hast alles erzählt, was du uns sagen wolltest. Wunderbar, dann vielen Abend. Ach, vielen Abend. So, und dann haben wir Aline. Der hat eine Frage. Wenn das doof Gerät zu funktionieren würde, das ist ja viel zu digital. Ja, funktioniert nicht. Wo haben wir eigentlich stehen geblieben?
Genau, wir haben bei dir stehen geblieben, Bündelfunk. Was da passiert ist, das Handfunkgerät nimmt Kontakt mit einer Basisstation auf, also dieser Zelle, die nimmt den Ruf an, vermittelt ihn weiter zu dem Zielgerät. Und da gibt es nun allerhand Möglichkeiten, die noch dazukommen. Also man kann zum Beispiel auch ganz normal telefonieren, also man kann auch dem Funkgerät, wenn es dafür freigeschaltet ist im Netz, auch eine Telefonnummer eintippen und dann damit telefonieren mit einem normalen Mobiltelefon. Man kann Kurznachrichten schicken und man kann halt allerhand andere Dinge tun, die ja so möglich sind in solchen digitalen Verfahren, zum Beispiel Datenübertragung. Man kann ja an der Web klicken, dafür reicht es nicht. Das ist so eines dieser Problempunkte bei diesem Tetra-System. Nach heutigen Maßstäben ist die Bandbreite des Systems halt echt lächerlich. Also man kriegt halt maximal so was wie 28.8 hin. Das sind die Modems, die wir vor zehn Jahren weggeschmissen haben.
Nein, nein, nein, die ganzen ersten Modems. Ich hatte einen Akustik-Koppler, der machte 300 Baut pro Sekunde.
Ja, naja, das ist aber schon 15 Jahre hier.
Wir machen aber jetzt kein Methode-Line-Wettbewerb, sondern wir zahlen jetzt Schäter nochmal. Sehr viel besser.
Gleich viel besser, ok.
So, jetzt erzähl mal von deinem Erlebnis mit dem Digitalfunkgerät.
Ja, also wir hatten die Geräte in den Fingern und da natürlich, da wo wir waren, noch kein Tetra Netz herrschte, musste man mit den Geräten im sogenannten Direktmod arbeiten. Kann man vielleicht nachher nochmal drauf eingehen, direkt gegenüber Trunk, also Netzmodus. Das heißt, die haben an und für sich funktioniert, wie man früher die oder wie man jetzt auch noch die Analoggeräte hat, solange alle Geräte denselben Kanal sozusagen eingestellt haben oder die digitale Variante davon, können alle mithören. Das ist einfach das, was es nicht, was sie zumindest mal nicht vorhaben oder was es geben wird, aber es ist nur eine Möglichkeit von dem Ganzen. Und dann funktioniert ein Gerät einfach so, dass man einmal sozusagen diese Sprechkaste drückt, wie zum Funken und dann sagt einem das Gerät erstmal, jetzt ist ein Kanal frei für dich oder nicht. Du darfst oder darfst nicht. Und es ist einfach irgendwie bis zu einer Sekunde noch mal Verzögerung, bis man dann wirklich loslegen darf.
Tatsächlich eine Sekunde, ja. Weil eigentlich war ja der, gab ja eine große Diskussion darum, ob es jetzt so ein Tetra wird oder ein aufgebohrtes Mobilfunknetz für den Behördenfunk. Und einer der wesentlichen Argumente war ja, dass die der Verbindungsaufbau nicht zu lange dauern sollte. Und was halt so mit so aufgebohrten Mobilfunk, also wie zum Beispiel GSMR, was die Bahn benutzt, die haben halt so ein spezielles Mobilfunknetz, was halt darauf optimiert ist, zum Beispiel besonders schnell einen Verbindungsaufbau zu machen. Und die sind glaube ich bei anderthalb Sekunden oder so was. Und eigentlich sollte bei Tetras doch eher bei 400 Millisekunden oder weniger sein.
Ja, also gefühlt war es mindestens eine halbe Sekunde, also ein Rund, so bis es mal piepste dann.
Aber warte mal, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, Peter, war es bei dir ja auch sozusagen nur die Direktverbindung zwischen zwei Funkgeräten?
Das ist einfach Broadcast, wie man es bisher auch kennt, also einfach rausschicken. Und selbstverständlich wird aber geprüft, ob dieser Kanal gerade Freie zusprechen.
Und das dauert eine Weile. Im IRC-Chat, irc.freenote.net tauchte gerade die Frage auf, wenn das Funknetze sind, die wirklich so Funkzellen haben, auch die müssen ja von irgendjemand betrieben werden, wer macht das da?
Das ist die Bundesanstalt für Digitalfunk.
Okay, wir haben eine neue Institution dafür. Ja klar, natürlich.
Hey, wir sind ein Deutschlandmann. Da haben wir Behörden, bis der Arzt kommt.
Gibt es da ein Errichtungsgesetz zu?
Da gibt es...
Ja, Gesetz zur Errichtung des BDBOS vom 1. Juli 2005. Und der Schröder.
Ja, genau. Also die interessanter, was mich dabei interessieren würde ist, die haben ja eine ziemlich komplexe Möglichkeit, so Gruppen zu definieren. Also einer der Vorteile von Tetra ist, wenn bisher zum Beispiel die Feuerwehr und die Polizei und das Technische Hilfswerk zu einem Einsatzort kommen, dann müssen sie sich ja irgendwie verständigen. Und bisher war das ja mehr so mit Brüll über den Platz, so weit ich das verstanden habe. Oder man hatte möglicherweise noch die Telefonnummer von dem anderen Einsatzleiter oder so. Also jedenfalls war halt immer so ein Problem. Und einer der großen Vorteile von Tetra soll nun sein, dass man gemeinsame Gruppen bilden kann, also auch über mehrere Behörden hinweg, die halt an einem Einsatz teilnehmen. Ist denn das User Interface dafür so, dass man das benutzen kann? Oder ist das irgendwie alle ganz grausam?
Bevor du diese Frage beantwortest, Peter, hast du dein Radio noch an? Weil du Hals ganz schlimm.
Das User Interface wird keiner von euch hier in die Finger kriegen. Das wird in den Leitstellen, wenn ich das richtig sehe, gebaut werden. Da muss man halt mit den übrigen Jungs schmeißen, mal den und den und den und den alle in eine Gruppe. Gib mal Bescheid und dann reden wir weiter.
Ach das heißt, du siehst auf dem Funkgerät tatsächlich nur die für dich freigeschalteten Gruppen und kannst davon dann eine auswählen oder wie?
Genau, ich werde also, wenn ich das so weit ich das richtig sehe, ich werde nicht die Möglichkeit haben, mein Gerät mal eben in eine andere außer den mir freigegebenen Gruppen reinzuschubsen. Von da muss irgendwo aus dem Netz selber kommen und der nächste Ansprechpartner sind halt die hier bisher auch, die Leitstellen, die das dann wohl auf Zugruf machen werden können, hoffentlich.
Also das entspricht in dem Fall der Theorie, weil wir hatten es noch gar nicht vom Digitalfunk abgehören. Aber natürlich kann man Digitalfunk auch abhören, es sei denn, es ist verschlüsselt, da können wir so mal zusammenfassen. Und bei den Tetra für den Behördenfunk haben sie sich tatsächlich mal richtig, richtig doll Mühe gegeben. Also es ist nicht nur so, dass du nicht konfigurieren kannst, dass du in der Gruppe drin bist, nein, es ist so, dass jede Gruppe ihren eigenen Schlüssel hat, der aus einem Schlüssel in deiner Chipkarte abgeleitet wird. Und wenn du halt nicht freigeschaltet bist, hast du den Schlüssel nicht, um das zu dekodieren.
Ja, also dieses Verschlusseskonzept, also die Idee dahinter ist folgende. Tetra an sich ist ja ein digitales Funksystem, was man erstmal nicht so mit einem normalen Amateurfunk-Empfänger abhören kann. Das war also Ziel eins. Aber dann dachten die sich, naja gut, wir stellen das jetzt für 30 Jahre hin. In der Zeit werden Leute schon auf die Idee kommen, Empfänger zu bauen, mit denen man aus solchen digitalen Verfahren abhören kann. Eine nicht ganz unberechtigte Annahme. Also machen wir dann noch mal eine runde Verschlüsselung drauf. Und jetzt ist es so, dass in jedem von diesen Tetrafunkgeräten kommt eine Chipkarte rein. Die sieht halt genauso aus wie so eine normale SIM in so einem GSM. Wie kennt man ja so PriPAD-SIM ins GSM stecken. Ähm, so ähnlich sehen die Dinge auch aus, die in die Tetrafunkgeräte kommen. Und da ist dann Schlüsselmaterial drauf, mit dem sich das Gerät gegenüber dem Netz authentifizieren kann, das Netz sich gegenüber dem Gerät authentifizieren kann und auch eine Ende-zu-Ende Verschlüsselung zwischen zwei Geräten stattfinden kann. Also selbst wenn jemand versucht, das abzuhören, dann hört er dann nichts. Ich hab mal die interessante Frage gestellt, wie machen Sie es denn nun eigentlich mit der verpflichtenden Aufzeichnung? Ähm, der, äh, also die sind ja verpflichtet, Behörden für Ordnungssicherheitsaufgaben sind verpflichtet, dass der Funkverkehr aufgezeichnet wird, zu Zwecken der Beweislichung der gleichen Dinge. Und, äh, sie haben dann sehr einfache Lösungen für gefunden, und zwar werden die Aufzeichnungsgeräte einfach automatisch mit in die Sprachgruppen reingeschaltet, und haben dann so PC-basierte, äh, Systeme, also das ist dann halt so eine PC-Einstellkarte, die kann halt bis zu acht Gruppen gleichzeitig aufzeichnen, und hat dann die entsprechenden Authentifizierungsinformationen drauf. Und da ist dann halt also mal sozusagen ein Mithörer, wird halt immer mit in die Gruppe rein konfiguriert.
Warte mal, heißt das dann sozusagen, in Zukunft will ich dann nicht mehr ein einzelnes Funkgerät abhören, sondern die Aufgabe quasi zum Abhören ist dann, in den Computer in der Leitstelle zu kommen, und da gleich alles mitzunehmen?
Ja, also wenn man böswillig ist, denn interessant ist halt, dass die Interfaces für diese ganzen Leitstellen-Systeme sind halt alle über TCP-IP und betrieben wird das Ganze von T-Systems.
Okay, kurze Erklärung, falls noch jemand zuhört, der noch den Pfaden nicht verloren hat, obwohl er noch nicht so lange dabei ist. TCP-IP ist halt genau das, was im normalen Internet verwendet wird, was man total einfach abhören kann.
Naja, zumindest ist ein bekannter technischer Standard.
Und T-Systems ist jetzt vermutlich zumindest mal nicht so bekannt für...
Na, T-Systems sind die Leute, die halt zum Beispiel die Software am Arbeitsamt verkackt haben und ungefähr jedes Regierungssoftware Projekt, was in den letzten 15 Jahren viel geschlagen ist, ist von T-Systems gekommen.
Toll Collect.
Genau, Toll Collect war auch eins davon.
Okay, ein Bundesamt Syriums ist quasi eine Art Bewerbungsmappe, oder?
Ich glaube nicht, also das ist halt mehr so, die machen halt die Sachen, die sonst niemand mehr machen möchte und mit entsprechenden Ergebnissen.
Okay, so kommt es also mal zustande. Peter, bist du zufrieden mit dem, oder? Gibt es noch etwas, was du uns unbedingt sagen willst?
Ich bin gerade überlegen.
Habt ihr noch irgendwelche Fragen? Vielleicht weiß ich noch was.
Genau, ja. Wie ist denn so die allgemeine Erwartungshaltung bei den Feuerwehren, was jetzt diesen Digitalfunk angeht? Also es ist mir ein bisschen so das Fahrgefühl. Freuen sich da jetzt alle drauf, oder ist das eher so ein bisschen so na lass mal gucken, oder wo bleibt denn unser gutes Analog? Oder gibt es da vielleicht auch so Leute, die halt wie sagen, ich vermisse den Kratzen des Vinyls?
Oder ähnliches? Lass mal gucken, trifft schon eher. Also eigentlich sagen wir gut, es hat natürlich die Fehler wie nicht abhören und so. Oder im Moment kann man es halt abhören, was aber der Grund eher jetzt mal oder der Zwang, was dagegen zu tun hat, eher aus der Polizeiecke kommt. Die haben da die etwas höheren Anforderungen. Wenn man so guckt, sagen eigentlich alle, lass mal schauen, wie es wird. Man weiß im Moment, was haben wir jetzt? Wie funktioniert das? Funktioniert an und für sich ganz gut. Außer dass, wenn eine Frequenz mal voll ist, wenn einer sprich gleich mal voll ist, was ein bisschen besser werden wird. Allerdings überlegt man sich auch, wie das jetzt wird. Wie zum Beispiel ein Einzelleiter sonst irgendwas künftig mithören kann, was in seinem Einsatz passiert. Bis jetzt nimmt das Gerät, stellt auf dieselbe Frequenz, also auf den Kanal und hört einfach zu.
Und denn jetzt muss er dann in die Gruppe rein?
Unklar.
Also muss dann halt mit in die Gruppe rein konfiguriert werden?
Genau, der muss dann immer mit in die Gruppe rein. Auch was macht er, wenn es dann auf 2 und so weiter. Also wie man letztendlich mit umgeht, wird natürlich auch noch schwierig werden.
Und bei der Einführung werden da die alten Analoggeräte erstmal noch eine Weile weiter parallel benutzt? Oder wie wird das funktionieren?
Das wird noch unklar. Wir sind hier in Baden-Württemberg erst frühestens 2011 dran. Wie es dann letztendlich laufen wird, ich denke mal auch parallel. Also man wird schon mal ein paar Geräte kriegen, hier bespielt die schon mal.
Und dann werden die vorn aufs Armaturen wird gegaffert oder wie?
Ja, dann wird man gucken, ob man die alten jetzt rauswirft, gleich rauswirft, ob man die gleich irgendwie draufklebt. Noch zu der anderen Sache vorhin von Sven. Die Preise sollen also für Baden-Württemberg definitiv niedriger liegen. Man rechnet somit 400 Euro pro Gerät. Was dann auch schon wieder vergleichbar wird mit aktuellen.
Okay, das heißt also Baden-Württemberg kauft dann wahrscheinlich nicht das EADS, sondern die billigeren britischen oder so Geräte. Okay, verstehe. Ja, also das muss man vielleicht noch erwähnen, so eines der Dinge, die also Bedingungen für diese Tetra-Ausschreibungen waren, war, dass es mehrere Anbieter von Funkgeräten geben soll, damit die Behörden nicht nur einen Systemanbieter zur Auswahl haben. Sodass sie sich das aussuchen können, sagen können, wir kaufen lieber etwas preiswertere mit weniger Features oder die halt nicht so kratzbeißend lutschfest sind wie die anderen und macht daraus, ja kann damit halt dann irgendwie noch mal Geld sparen oder so. Das Netz wurde an sich von dieser Bundesanstalt für Digitalfunk betrieben, aber die Funkgeräte müssen die Länder halt selber kaufen. Das ist halt so der.
Also wenn ich das richtig höre, haben wir bis jetzt erfahren, wie Digitalfunk funktioniert und das eigentlich sozusagen, also ihr im Sinne von der Chaos Computer Club euch schon irgendwie darauf freut, weil neue Technik scheint mir so, aber die Leute, die damit arbeiten müssen, bis jetzt eher so semi begeistert sind.
Naja, man muss halt auch so sehen, so Leute, die dann abhängig von so Werkzeugen sind, wie zum Beispiel Feuerwehren, wir schneiden sie dann mal raus, die haben halt gerne Werkzeuge, von denen sie wissen, dass es funktioniert. Das heißt also, dass der erstmal natürlich die Skepsis bis so ein neues Werkzeug sich bewiesen hat groß. Also so ist doch Peter, oder?
Das wird so werden, weil die eingehen natürlich mit dem entsprechenden Elan dran, Juhu Spielzeug, lass mal gucken, wie es wird. Stehen dem auch schon ein bisschen vielleicht offener gegenüber, aber irgendjemand anderes, älteres, die dann gerät, was auf einmal statt fünf irgendwie vor noch fünf Knöpfen vorne auf einmal noch so eine Zehnertastatur drauf hat. Das wird schon anders werden.
Irgendwas ist ja immer. Wenn ihr euch gerade fragt, worum geht es denn hier? Es geht hier um Digitalfunk und das hat einen ganz einfachen Grund, warum es heute um so ein Thema geht, denn ihr seid hier.
Blum, die zwei Sprechstunden.
Dieser Sound bedeutet, ihr seid im Chaos Radio angekommen. Da geht es heute um Digitalfunk. Wir wollen nämlich heute mal wissen, was mit den neuen Funkgeräten ist, die die Berliner Polizei so kriegen soll. Und da haben wir jetzt Detlef an Telefonen. Der ist nämlich Polizeibeamter in Berlin und kann ein Wörtchen mitreden. Hallo und guten Abend. Du hast so ein digitales Funkgerät schon mal in der Hand gehabt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das in der Hand hatte, wobei ihr redet, aber ich habe das, was in Berlin, im Testteil Charlottenburg-Spandau über Jahre schon im Testbetrieb war. Und zwar ist das ein T3-Gerät von Motorola. Nur mal größer als ein normales Mobilfunkgerät und auch nicht mit dieser Nokia-Systematik aufgebaut, ein bisschen anders. Und wurde nun, jetzt ist der Testbetrieb einmal abgeschaltet worden. Jetzt wird das Betrieb insgesamt in den Dienstbetrieb überführt. Und jetzt laufen analog und digital, sag ich mal, parallel.
Und heißt das ja, ihr habt in den Fahrzeugen beide Geräte oder wie?
Genau, nicht nur zwei Geräte, eigentlich drei Geräte, weil ja in den Fahrzeugen selbst ein eingebautes 4-Meter-Gerät ist, wer damit umgehen kann, weiß, dass das anders arbeitet als das Handgerät und obendrein dazu jetzt das T3-Gerät. Also zwei Mann, drei Funkgeräte. Es bleibt mitunter solche Blüken, dass da vier, fünf, sechs Kollegen an einem Einsatzort kommen, aber nicht miteinander funken können, weil unterschiedliche Standards verteilt sind.
Das heißt, die einen haben noch die Analogtechnik, die anderen nur digital?
Analog haben eigentlich alle. Aber gelegentlich hat eben einer dann sein analoges nicht mit, sondern ein Tetra. Und der kann mit keinem Fahrzeug und mit keinem anderen Fußgänger kommunizieren. Nur mit der Tetra-Zentrale.
Verstehe. Und die kann dann maximal noch auf analog rüber vermitteln oder wie?
Könnte dann bestenfalls zwei Hörer gleichzeitig in der Hand halten, genau. Denn die kann auch nicht von analog auf digital schalten. Das geht auch nicht.
Gibt da kein Geld wieder zwischen? Wie hat sich das denn ausgedacht?
Nicht, dass ich wüsste. Dass es zwischen diesem Analogen und diesem Digitalen irgendwas noch gibt.
Und wie sind denn so die Erfahrungen? Man hört ja mal wieder, dass es so ein bisschen kritisch ist mit der Reichweite in Gebäuden und so. Habt ihr da schon Erfahrungen?
Ja, aber im Gegensatz, also die mit der Reichweite in Gebäuden hat ja jedes Funkgerät seine Schwierigkeiten. Und wenn ein Autonormalfahrbraucher der Bürger wüsste, wie geordenerhaft schlecht die Reichweite der analogen Geräte ist, dann würde jeder Bürger ein Zehner extra geben, damit ich endlich einen vernünftigen kriege. Also der Spruch bitte wechseln Sie Ihren Standort, ich kann Sie nicht aufnehmen. Den hört man auch heute noch fast täglich. Weil das Analogenetz eben nicht flächendeckend zwischen den Häuserzeilen ist, sondern manchmal geht ein, zwei Meter nach links und nach rechts und dann hab ich wieder eine Verbindung.
Verstehe die Wellenthele. Und mit den Digitalen ist das da ähnlich oder fühlt sich das anders an?
Nein, war das ähnlich, aber da ist ein immenser Aufwand betrieben worden. Wann immer, wir sind aufgefordert worden, möglichst viel damit zu funken. Macht man natürlich nur dann, wenn man es sich leisten kann, wenn man nicht darauf angewiesen ist, dass es immer funktioniert. Aber sobald wir eine Fehlfunktion bemerkt haben, Standort, ich sage mal, Tarantin, Breitscheidplatz, Wurms vor dem Wasserklopf, Verbindungen hinter dem Wasserklopf Kleine, dann gab es dafür bei uns eine Dienststelle, die da händesehend darauf gewartet hat, dass solche Meldungen gekommen sind. Und die sind dann ganz gezielt diese Funklöcher ausgemerzt worden.
Okay, das hat schon systematisch im Testbetrieb versucht worden?
Das ist auf den Westteil beschränkt gewesen, weil man versucht hat, mit welchem Aufwand das da realisierbar ist und ob das dann letzten Endes auch geht. Und die sind dann massenhaft dann auch tatsächlich mit diesen Informationen überschwemmt worden. Später dann war die nächste Stufe dann mit die Verbindungsqualität in Gebäuden. Und wenn man so einen 100 Jahre alten, ich vergleiche das mit dem Amtsgericht oder mit dem Kriminalgericht, in so einem Gebäude wieder Winkel findet und sagt, hier habe ich keinen Kontakt, dann können die irgendwo gegensteuern und dann kriegt man eben doch deutlich die digitale Verbindung.
Also du bist sozusagen optimistisch, dass es mit dem Digitalfunk am Ende besser wird?
Es wird wesentlich besser. Für mich, ich weiß nicht, die Feuerwehr hat nicht ein Problem, vorhin hat ein Kollege von der Feuerwehr gesprochen, der sagte, er weiß nicht, worum die das kriegen. Ich habe so oft in meinem täglichen Dienst damit zu tun oder beschäftige andere Leute damit zu tun, für mich irgendwo anzurufen. Ich sage eine Telefonnummer durch und sage, bitte rufen Sie dort an und fragen Sie ob. Zum Beispiel. Und das kann ich mit dem Teil selber, selbst eine Funkbeziehung, also mit dem Mobilfunk kann ich damit einwählen. Wer und wo da irgendwas mit schreibt und mit liest, ist mir in dem Sinne eigentlich auch völlig schnuppel, weil er immer einen dienstlichen Bezug hat, was ich damit telefoniere. Das kann ich also rechtfertigen. Wenn ich mich mal rechtfertigen müsste, ist noch nicht vorgekommen. Aber das vereinfacht viele Sachen, wenn ich direkt mit den Leuten sprechen kann, von denen ich was will.
Das heißt also, du erwartest schon, dass es im normalen Dienstalter einfach einfacher wird?
Hat schon, ist ja schon. Wir haben ja über Jahre diesen Testbetrieb und wir haben auch noch diese alten Tetra-Teile, die irgendwann wieder abgeschaltet werden, wenn es dann diese Satzgeräte gibt, die da jetzt in Mitte eingeführt worden sind.
Wie ist denn da jetzt so der Einführungszeitplan? Also wie schnell wird das gehen in Berlin?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Also wird jetzt erst mal sukzessive in Mitte eingeführt und dann...
Das ist die offizielle Pressemeldung, dass die ersten 1000 Geräte jetzt ausgeliefert werden sollen. Und irgendeiner hat mal feierlich das erste Gerät überreicht.
Das lassen sich ja immer nicht entgehen.
Ja genau, aber das ist ja beim Wachtmeister nicht angekommen. Der Wachtmeister hat die Zwei-Meter-Technik. Und die Zwei-Meter-Technik, das Handfunkgerät ist 30 Jahre alt. So alt sind fast alle, oder 35 jetzt inzwischen, so alt sind fast alle Geräte und halb so alt sind alle Akkus. Also nur nach dem Motto, warum brauchen wir was Neues, wenn ich den Leuten sage, ich habe immer ein Reserveakku mit, weil ich nie weiß, wie lange hält mein Akku.
Das heißt, der hält nicht einen Tag durch, oder wie?
Um Gottes Willen, mal hatte ich einen der ältesten Tag, aber ich hab auch mal eine der ältesten Stunde. Oder der kommt voll geladen aus dem Ladegerät, die dann automatisch geht und entladen. Da sind immer riesen Batterien, muss ich vorstellen. Ich mache vielleicht mit, sagen wir mal, mit einer Nachtschicht von 30 Mann. Der hat ständig 50 Akkus zum Laden und Entladen. Und jeder, der kommt, reinkommt und genau weiß, ich hab schon ein paar Mal gefunkt, der schmeißt einen halb vollen oder ich weiß nicht, wie viel noch drin vollen Akku, renne in den Ladenschacht und nimmst den vollen wieder raus. Wie lange der hält, weiß er aber nicht. Also es ist schon diverse Male. Man kann dann zwar noch empfangen, wenn der Akku fast leer ist, aber man kann nicht mehr senden. Jeder, der das Lied kennt, wird dann wissen, wie oft ihr es nicht aufnehmen könnt, bitte kommen Sie überdrehen. Und dann hol ich mein Privat-Handy raus und sage, nur manchmal ist es ja auch wichtig, dass man ne Meldung los wird, dass irgendetwas nicht so schlimm ist, wie gedacht. Dass sich irgendetwas nicht bestätigt hat. Na ja, dafür nehme ich dann mein Privat-Handy.
Und wie ist das? Habt ihr da in dem Feldversuch jetzt auch schon die Datendienste ausprobiert, so für Halteabfragen und ähnliche Dinge?
Das funktioniert ja sowieso über Draht bei uns. Also, die mache ich ja nicht selber. Ich rufe irgendwo an, wo ich die Auskünfte kriege.
Verstehe, das heißt, das macht ihr noch nicht über das Tetra-System?
Das würde ich auch nicht machen wollen. Dafür ist die Tastatur für so unpraktisch. Also machen wir uns nichts vor. Wir sind ja, wenn ich da bin, ich bin ja kein SMS-Künstler. Mein Telefon hab ich in der Hand und meine Umgebung muss ich wahrnehmen. Wenn ich dann anfangen soll auf dieser Tastatur, die doppelt, ich sag mal, bei der Motorola ist die doppelt so groß wie wenn, eine Telefon-Tastatur.
Also das heißt, du würdest aber die neuen Funkgeräte sozusagen nur deswegen gut finden, weil sie halt zuverlässiger funken, aber sozusagen diese Datendienste wären dir eigentlich egal, weil das halt sozusagen zu viel wäre.
Noch sind sie mir egal. Wenn ich denn in meinem übernächsten Funkwagen, in dem Auslieferungszustand 2020 tatsächlich auch eine mobile Schreibmaschine habe, dann brauche ich natürlich eine zuverlässige Datenverbindung in meiner Abfragesysteme.
Das heißt, du würdest das schon gut finden, wenn sie irgendwie über das T-Dra dann die Fahndungsbilder dann auf einem Laptop in einen Streifenwagen irgendwie senden.
Das wird mit Sicherheit nicht gehen. Natürlich gibt es von vielen Personen, die mal erkennungsdienstlich behandelt wurden, zum Beispiel Bilder, die ich abfragen kann, wenn ich an meinem Dienst PC sitze.
Aber kannst du halt nicht unterwegs.
So etwas kann ich alles nicht vor Ort machen. Das ist also viel zu aufwendig. Das ist keine rollende Büro. Ich brauche eine mobile Schreibmaschine, wo ich Sachverhalte die Wahrnehmung schnell zu Papier bringen kann oder überhaupt nur Notizen zu machen. Aber die richtige Vorgangsfertigung, was Hand und Fuß haben muss, was zum Schluss beim Richter liegt, das kann ich nicht auf der Straße machen. Und dann auch nebenbei gucken, ob mir jemand über die Schulter schaut. Machen wir uns das nicht vor. Das sind ja dann alles hochsensive Daten. Ich müsste in einem halb abgedunkelten Fahrzeug sitzen und die Zugriff von fremden Leuten müsste ich wieder ausschließen können. Guckt einer rein und sagt, was macht der denn? Es geht alles nicht.
Ich fürchte, die Leute, die das geplant haben, machen sich solche Gedanken nicht.
Doch, das machen die. Zumindest, was bei uns die Datensicherheit angeht.
Zumindest so was wie Halterabfrage überfunktet, hat man ständig gelesen überall als das neue Feature. Ja, jetzt gibt es auch Datendaste und so.
Natürlich kann ich die Halterabfrage überfunkt machen. Theoretisch, aber praktisch. Wenn ich heute eine Halterabfrage mache, ruf ich an bei der Fahndungsstelle und sage, ich brauche zudem und dem Fahrzeug folgende Auskünfte. Und der sieht an meiner Nummer, dass das ein Tetra ist und kann mir die Auskünfte geben. Könnte ja jeder Vollidioter anrufen und den Nachbarn abfragen oder was. Wenn die Nummer erstmal bekannt ist. Das ist ja eine Nummer, die man vom öffentlichen Apparat auch anwählen könnte, wenn man sie dann wüsste.
Okay, sagen Sie jetzt nicht...
Da sitzt ja jemand am Telefon an seinem Rechner und der macht nichts anderes als den ganzen Tag Fahndungsabfragen, weil den ganzen Tag bei ihrem Kollegen sagen, ich brauche zu dem Fahrzeug diese Nummer. Und es geht bei dem auch am schnellsten. Der antwortet mir nicht und sagt mir, was ich hören will.
Okay, also Digitalfunk quasi nur zum Funken, der Rest wird nachher von Menschen gemacht. Noch eine Frage an Detlef?
Ich interessiere mich bloß dafür, wie oft es passiert, dass man zu irgendeinem, keine Ahnung was passiert, irgendein Tatort kommt und da steht schon die Presse.
Mehrfach. Also und richtig übel, wo ich sage, mein lieber Herr Gesangverein, es wird höchste Zeit, dass man da was vorschiebt. Kann ich eine Geschichte aus dem wahren Leben erzählen? Ein Wohnungsbrand mit mehreren Toten. Ich bin der erste Funkwanger am Ort gewesen und hab dann meine Telefonnummer durchgegeben und ihr sagt ab jetzt nur noch über diese Nummer, weil ich wusste draußen die Feuerwehr Riesen aufgebohrt und noch bevor mich mein Vorgesetzter anrufen konnte, klingelt mein Telefon, stellt sich jemand vor, guten Tag, ich bin der und der und wie du bist denn aus da oben? Dann hab ich gefragt und der hat sich mit dem Namen des Abschnittsleiters vorgestellt, mit dem Nachnamen. Dann hab ich gesagt, wie heißen Sie denn mit Vornamen? Dann hat er einen Vornamen genannt und dann hab ich gesagt, tut mir leid für Sie, mein Abschnittsleiter heißt anders. Die haben also sowieso alles mitgehört und waren schneller als die Dienststelle mich anzurufen. Ja und das war diejenige Sache, die war ja nicht zu übersehen. Ein brennendes Hochhaus, sag ich mal, das sieht man ja. Mit Auswirkungen auf den Straßenverkehr, am hellerlichten Tare, das kann man ja noch verstehen. Aber ich hab auch schon einen Suizid gehabt, Nacht um drei, wo an allen Türen Kollegen standen, im Innenhof, ohne jede Außenwirkung und plötzlich, bevor die Kriminalpolizei da war, von Balkons mit glücklich geschlossen worden.
Das heißt, du erwartest dir von dem digitalen Funk und der Verschlüsselung dann auch so ein bisschen Diskretion in der Richtung?
Na ja, Diskretion, ich sag mal, die Presse, die sich in Hubschrauber reinsetzt, um einen Verkehrsunfall zu fotografieren, der von Leuten, die eigentlich zum Retten und Bergen und zum Helfen da sind, die damit beschäftigt sind, irgendwelche Planen hochzuhalten, sind es schon makaber genug. Die werden also immer Wege finden. Aber es macht natürlich viele Sachen sicher. Und obendrein kann mir auch nicht jemand dazwischen sprechen. Was ich zum Beispiel mit dem Tetra noch nie beobachtet habe, aber beim Analog-Funk gang und gäbe ist, dass funkferngesteuerte Ampeln den Verkehr stören. Die Protokollstrecken von Tegel, Intrigierungen, Zürtel, durch die halbe Stadt, die können ja zentral geschaltet werden. Ampelausfall ist gar nicht. Die schalten zwei Minuten bevor die Kolonne kommt alle Ampeln aus, so wie sie sie brauchen, und zwei Minuten später wieder ein. Und wenn ich das auf einer Hauptverkehrsstraße mache, staut sich natürlich in fünf Minuten wat.
Und dann, wenn das passiert, dann stört das den Analogfunk?
Nein, grundsätzlich, die Ampel kommuniziert ständig mit der Verkehrsleitzentrale. Die wissen also immer den Ampelzustand, wie er gerade schaltet. Und können da eingreifen. Also ein hochmodernes System.
Also per Funk oder?
Auf welcher Basis die das schalten, weiß ich nicht, aber es ist alles funkgesteuert.
Und dann, dass die Signale von den Ampeln stören, das analoge Funkgerät, aber das geht nicht. Aber nur mit den Analogen, also mit digitalen Geräten funktioniert das dann?
Im digitalen funktioniert das, genau.
Die haben auch eine andere Frequenz.
Wenn ich tatsächlich so einen ungünstigen Standort habe, muss ich mein großes Funkgerät ausmachen, weil es nur am Knarren ist.
Einblicke ins Berliner Polizeileben von Detlef, vielen Dank dafür. Ihr seid hier nämlich im Chaos Radio auf Fritz, wo es um Digitalfunk heute geht. Wir haben jetzt schon gelernt, wie digital funktioniert, dass die Behörden ihn bekommen sollen und dass es manche Leute gibt, die sagen, ja das ist ganz cool und manche, die sagen, naja eigentlich brauchen wir es nicht so richtig. Ich wäre jetzt für eine Runde Musik, was sagt ihr? Ich habe ja in der Vorbereitung dieser Sendung natürlich gedacht, der Chaos Radio, Chaos Computer Club, da muss er Musik aus dem Netz machen, habe auch ein bisschen rumgefragt im Chat, war da irgendwie kaum mal am Start. Also anscheinend ist Netzmusik noch gar nicht so verbreitet, den kreisen, wie ich das dachte, deswegen möchte ich euch das präsentieren und mitbringen. Jetzt gibt es Professor Klick, total großartig, Plastic and Flashing Lights.
Und bald wieder.
Der außergewöhnliche und supergeniale Professor Klick mit Plastic and Flashing Lights, der auch im Chat auf große Zustimmung gestoßen ist. Im Chat ist auch noch die Frage aufgetaucht, hey, wenn sich GSM und Tetrafunk so ähneln, warum nennt man da nicht einfach die GSM Zellen zum Tetrafunken?
Der wesentliche Grund ist die Rufaufbauzeit. Es gab ja den Vorschlag, als es um diesen digitalen Behördenfunk ging, einfach zu sagen, okay, wir bohren einfach die GSM Netze ein bisschen auf, also die normalen Mobilfunknetze bohren die ein bisschen auf, so dass man darüber halbwegs gesichert Behördenkommunikation abwickeln kann. Und das Problem war, dass sie die Rufaufbauzeiten, also die Zeit, wo wenn du auf die Taste drückst, bis das auf der anderen Seite blieb macht, dass sie die nicht irgendwie unter vier Sekunden bekommen haben. So und die Anforderung in der Ausschreibung war, halt irgendwie zu sagen, halbe Sekunde oder weniger. So sollte halt das sein, weil wenn da so ein Feuerwehrmann im brennenden Haus steht oder so ein Polizist irgendwie...
Die Verbindung wird gehalten.
Genau. Der eine Grund, der andere Grund ist, dass man dann natürlich Kapazitäten im GSM-Netz garantieren müsste, die auch unter extremen Bedingungen immer zur Verfügung stehen. Und dafür ist das GSM-Netz schlicht nicht gebaut. Die Mobilfunknetze sind halt, wenn der Strom ausfällt, dann laufen die vielleicht maximal noch sechs Stunden weiter. Und so die Tetranetze, Tetranetze wird halt dafür aufgebaut, sehr viel länger auch noch zu funktionieren. Selbst wenn der Strom weg ist, sind halt Akkus drin und Generatoren.
Okay, also im Prinzip ist es eine ähnliche Technologie, aber es macht also sagen technisch nicht so gleich, dass man es einfach zusammenwerfen könnte. Genau. Bevor wir jetzt tatsächlich dann aber zum GSM-Netz kommen, wollte ich noch kurz Matthias dran nehmen. Matthias hat nämlich den Morse-Code vielleicht gelöst, der am Anfang der Sendung gespielt wurde. Habt ihr den noch mal kurz da?
Oh nein, wo ist er? Extra Punkte. Gibt auch noch Eiszomate.
Großartig. Matthias, was war das für ein Morse-Code?
Also ich meine, dass das SOS war.
Falsch.
Du hast verloren.
Also du kriegst Bonus-Kunden, Kürpunkte für Morse-Code vorsingen und überhaupt anrufen, weil du bist der Erste, der das versucht hat.
Genau, aber es war leider nicht so trivial.
Können wir noch mal hören?
Wir spielen nochmal ab.
Ja, ihr habt noch eine halbe Stunde Zeit, um das zu versuchen zu lösen.
Amateur-Funker sind irgendwie am Aussterben, oder? Besonders solche, die morsen können.
Oder die gucken noch Fußball, oder ist Fußball fertig?
Also wenn ich so sehe, was da... Das ist das Fernsehprogramm, wo vorhin noch Fußball war. Man muss ja immer informiert bleiben. Okay, Matthias, das war es leider nicht. Trotzdem danke für den Anruf.
Also das Fernsehprogramm, Matthias, läuft ja nämlich so ein bisschen um einen Spim-Folder.
Ja, das ist natürlich alles den Recherchezwecken. Gut, kommen wir doch nun zu etwas völlig Anderem. GSM. Genau, weil also Digitalfunk, um das es heute geht, ist zum einen dieser Behördenfunk, über den wir jetzt schon die ganze Zeit geredet haben, zum anderen aber auch das Stinknormale-Handynetz, was ja wirklich alle kennen, die vor den Radiogeräten sitzen. Das funktioniert auch so. Kann man damit auch Spaß haben?
Klar, also so ein GSM-Netz gibt es ja schon seit 1996, glaube ich. Korrigiert mich ungefähr, so 1996 wurden die ersten D-Netze tatsächlich installiert und der Vorteil von wie gesagt Digitalfunk wurde da auch relativ schnell deutlich. Man konnte Geräte kleiner und billiger bauen, man konnte sehr viel mehr Benutzer auf der gleichen Menge Frequenzen unterbringen. Das war ja auch so ein wesentlicher Punkt, dass man halt also, vorher gab es halt dieses C-Netz, also diese analogen Mobilfunksysteme, da konnte man halt auch nicht so richtig doll viele Benutzer mit gleichzeitig bedienen, weil die doch immer einen Funkkanal brauchten pro Gespräch. Und diese Funkkanäle gab es halt nicht so besonders viele, deswegen war da halt irgendwann Schluss, gab auch kein SMS und irgendwie die Benachrichtigung, dass jetzt zwar davon Anrufbeantworter sind, diese ganzen Dinge, die gab es halt alle nicht so richtig. Das war halt alles sehr analog und das klang halt auch so ein bisschen wie Funk, also muss man sagen, so die Gesprächsqualität war etwas räudig. Die Geräte waren so groß wie Briketts und hatten auch ungefähr dasselbe Gewicht und das hat sich dann halt alles geändert mit dem Aufkommen vom D-Netz. Im Wesentlichen ist das GSM-Protokoll Ende der 80er, Anfang der 90er spezifiziert worden. Also es hat schon doch ziemlich alt und gut abgehangen und wie immer bei solchen Technologien ist es so, dass es eine Weile dauert, bis die so in das Feld kommen, wo man als Hobbyist damit auch was anfangen kann, also damit halt selber rumspielen kann und bei GSM ist es jetzt mittlerweile so weit, dass wir so in diesen Bereich kommen. Das heißt, dass es gibt jetzt eine ganze Menge interessante Projekte, zum Beispiel sich eigene GSM-Basis-Stationen zu bauen.
Also wir machen unser eigenes GSM-Netz.
Genau.
Also sprich, es gibt ja in Zukunft Telekom, wo davon O2 und E+, und das C-Netz, das TCC-Netz.
Genau, wir könnten mal wieder ein C-Netz machen, ja das wäre doch tatsächlich mal irgendwie eine Option. Genau. Also die Idee dabei ist halt folgende, die Technologie ist mittlerweile so gut verstanden und nach heutigen Maßstäben einfach, dass man in der Lage ist, sie selber zu bauen. Da kannst du vielleicht noch ein bisschen was zu erzählen.
Ja, vor allem offen standardisiert, was natürlich ein großer Vorteil ist bei der Entwicklung von Software in der Richtung. Da hat in dem Bereich Harald Welter aus unserem Club bei eBay eine BTS erstanden, eine BS11 Abis von Sie und...
Ein was?
Er hat eine BTS, eine Base Transceiver Station. Das sind die Dinger, die überall auf den Dächern rumstehen mit den lustigen Antennen.
Denkt an ein Modem.
Genau, denkt an ein Modem, die uns das Netz machen, also sprich die Sender und Empfänger.
Das sind diese großen Masken auf den Häusern, wo die sich viele Boxen haben. Das ist eine von diesen Boxen oder was?
Genau, also so ein Ding wie sie da auf den Dächern sind. Das ist halt eine große graue Kiste, wiegt ungefähr 30 Kilo, also ist ein bisschen zu schwer. Die Geräte sind halt ein bisschen älter, also die sind halt nicht umsonst jetzt auf eBay gewesen, weil sie halt überall abgeschraubt wurden, wo sie halt durch Neuere ersetzt wurden. Das ist halt so eines dieser Projekte, denn so ein Ding einfach mal zu nehmen und zu gucken, wie bekommt man die dazu, dass man sein Telefon darauf einbuchen kann.
Also das wäre dann quasi eine Funkzelle.
Genau, das sind eine Funkzelle.
So ein bisschen mehr als nur eine davon gefunden.
Genau, es gibt halt ein paar mehr davon. Also es ist halt nicht so, dass es nur eine gibt.
Okay, das hört sich total spannend an. Und ich würde deswegen sagen, wir hören jetzt oft drüber zu reden.
Und machen Nachrichten.
Cliffhanger und so und machen Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr. Und danach werden wir darüber reden, wie wir unser ganz eigenes GM-Netz aufbauen. Ich bin schon sehr gespannt.
Tja, und das haben sie jetzt davon. Das Berlin Festival. Laute neue, aber vor allem lauter neue Musik live auf dem Flughafen Tempelhof. Mit Bonaparte. Jose González, Dendemann und The Rhytles. Mit den Junior Boys Who Made Who, The Killians und Deichkid. Und das sind längst noch nicht alle. Das Berlin-Festival. Am 7. und 8. August auf dem Flughafen Templo, mitten in Berlin. Karten gibt's überall, wo's Karten gibt und mehr Infos fritz.de. Das Berlin-Festival. Neue Musik live von der Open Airport.
Fritz Info.
Nachrichten. Mit Liane Grus.
Im Berliner Kanzleramt wird immer noch über die Zukunft des Opel Konzerns beraten. Die Bundesregierung will bei den Verhandlungen eine Überbrückungsfinanzierung für den Autobauer beschließen. Außerdem soll geklärt werden, wie Opel aus der drohenden Insolvenz von General Motors herausgehalten werden kann. Die drei Investoren Fiat, Magna und Ripplewood stellen noch einmal ihre Konzepte für eine Übernahme des Konzerns vor. Mit einer Festlegung auf einen der Interessenten ist nach Einschätzung von Regierungssprecher Wilhelm aber nicht zu rechnen. Die Streiks in den kommunalen Kindertagesstätten gehen weiter. Nach Gesprächen mit den Arbeitgebern in Berlin erklärte die Gewerkschaft Verdi, die Tarifverhandlungen für die rund 220.000 Beschäftigten für vorerst gescheitert. Der kommunale Arbeitgeberverband hatte ein Angebot zum Gesundheitsschutz vorgelegt, das sowohl Verdi als auch die GEW als nicht akzeptabel zurückwiesen. Heute beteiligten sich bundesweit rund 15.000 Beschäftigte an dem Ausstand in Kindergärten, Horten, Jugendzentren und Beratungsstellen. In Berlin hat es bei den Mathe-Prüfungen für den mittleren Schulabschluss heute erneut eine Panne gegeben. Wir im letzten Jahr kursierten wieder Prüfungsaufgaben im Internet. Allerdings waren es diesmal die falschen. Ein Sprecher vom Bildungssenat sagte, jemand habe die Aufgaben vom letzten Jahr mit einem neuen Deckblatt ins Netz gestellt. Die aktuellen Aufgaben sollen aber nicht durchgesickert sein. Wegen einer solchen Panne mussten letztes Jahr 28.000 Berliner Zehntklässler die Mathe-Prüfung wiederholen. Sport! Der FC Barcelona hat die Champions League gewonnen. In Rom besiegte der spanische Fußballmeister, äh, Entschuldigung, der spanische Fußballmeister Manchester United mit 2 zu 0. Barcelona holte damit als erste spanische Meisterschaft den Dreiersieg aus Meisterschaft, spanischem Pokal und dem Champions League Titel. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen Potsdam-Cottbus, Angermünde 12 Grad, Frankfurt in Europin 13 und Bittenberg 14 und auch in Berlin 14 Grad. Es gibt noch ein paar Schauer am Abend. Es kann windig draußen sein. Bei Temperaturen zwischen 11 und 7 Grad. Tagsüber dann kommt die Sonne zwar raus, aber auch Wolken und etwas Regen sind wieder mit dabei bei 18 Grad. A10 westlicher Berliner Ring Richtung Dreikafelland zwischen Potsdam Nord und Spandau. Das ist ein defekter LKW. Hier ist die linke Spur gesperrt. Und die A24 Berlin Richtung Hamburg zwischen Dreikafelland und Dreikwitzstock Dossel. Da fährt ein Schwertransport. Hier kommt ihr nicht vorbei. Ansonsten Reutz, gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 103, 2 dann Fritz rund um Spanberg.
Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Mit Markus Richter, Frank Krieger, Björn Heller und Andreas Bug, der immer verschwunden ist, wenn die Nachrichten kommen, im Chaosradio, was heute um Digitalfunk geht. Und Digitalfunk ist das, wo man jetzt denkt, was soll denn das sein? Aber das ist das, was wir ganz viel verwenden, zum Beispiel Mobilfunk auch. Und Mobilfunk ist so alt und so gut abgehangen, wie die Kollegen vom CCC gesagt haben, dass man sich das vielleicht sogar schon selber bauen kann.
Genau, die Idee dabei ist einfach, diese Telefon haben in der Tasche, die kosten nichts mehr. Wir haben ganze Schubladenfeuer von unseren alten Telefonen, da weiß auch niemand mehr, wo man damit hin soll. Und eigentlich wollen wir zumindest auf unseren Veranstaltungen und ähnlichen Gelegenheiten ein eigenes GSM Netz haben. Das ist mittlerweile im Rahmen des Möglichen und da gibt es halt mehrere Varianten dahin zu kommen. So ein GSM Netz besteht halt aus den Basisstationen, das sind also die Dinger, die auf den Dächern sind. Und dahinter braucht man dann auch so ein paar andere Komponenten, also die dann da machen, dass man das Funksignal, was auf der Basisstation ankommt, dass es auf den Draht geleitet wird, also umgewandelt wird, in die Vermittlungsstelle geht und mit den anderen Telefonen, die möglicherweise auf einer anderen Basisstation sind, verbunden wird.
Und ihr habt jetzt als Gerät erst mal nur dieses Funkding?
Genau, erst ist halt erst mal nur die Basisstation so. Und der Rest ist eigentlich nur Software. Software, wie wir wissen, gibt es halt mittlerweile ja im Open Source und solchen Dingen. Und da können halt viele Leute dran mitmachen, da muss man nicht im Moment Geld für bezahlen. Und das ist das, was gerade läuft. Also da gibt es halt so ein, ein Projekt ist halt zum Beispiel diese... Genau, OpenBSC. Der BSC steht für Base Station Controller. Das ist halt ein Stück Software, was nichts weiter macht als mit diesen Funksystemen, also den Base Stations, die auf den Dächern sind, zu reden und denen zu sagen, was sie zu machen haben. Und mit denen, die halt, wenn da so ein Anruf reinkommt, wissen, hier kommt jetzt ein Datenstrom, der sieht aus wie ein Anruf. Und mit dem Anruf müssen wir mal verarbeiten und weiterleiten und daraus halt eine Vermittlung, also daraus könnte ein Gespräch werden, ist halt so die Aufgabe, die dann wiederum hinter dem Base Station Controller, im sogenannten MSC, im Mobile Switching Center angesiedelt ist. Und da gibt es halt noch so ein paar Komponenten, die halt so Netz machen.
Das heißt, da gibt es irgendwie diese Base Station, wo man quasi die Handys sich einbuchen könnten und müsst jetzt dieses, hoffentlich, wenn ihr seid, dabei, dieses Open BSC Projekt, das ist auch schon mal ganz ausführlich besprochen worden, im Chaos Radio Express und zwar mit der Nummer 120, hatte ich, glaube ich, wenn ihr das mal ganz ausführlich hören wollt, dann geht auf chaosradio.de. Dort gibt es nämlich die ganze Folge zum Runterladen. Und wie weit seid ihr denn jetzt? Also kann man schon oder ist es noch eher so theoretisch?
Ja, aktuell ist es halt schon möglich, irgendwie Handys einzubuchen, Handys untereinander sprechen zu lassen, also sprich einen Rufaufbau. Einer von der Uni, ich hab das letztens auf der Mailing-Liste gelesen, hat schon geschafft, irgendwie das Ganze per VoIP irgendwie ins Telefonnetz zu routen. Das heißt, man hat irgendwie schon so einen Grundstein, das ganze Ding produktiver einzusetzen. SMS, wie gesagt, sind auch möglich. Problemlos aktuell ist das halt ein bisschen so mehr Hacker-Gefrickel. Also sprich Konsolen basiert irgendwie nicht click und nicht für den normalen Hausgebrauch. Allerdings in die Richtung vermute ich mal, wird es auch irgendwann mal gehen. Das heißt, Hardware ist da, Hardware, die man halt nur braucht, irgendwie die BTS, hat man da, dann kriegt man irgendwie so eine PC-Einstellkarte für einen PC für 300 Euro und man hat irgendwie sein ganzes Setup für GSM fertig, kann sich das ins Zimmer stellen.
Was ist insgesamt 300 Euro für einen Kram?
Also die BTS irgendwie, die Verkauf der Harald Welte. Da müsste man ihn ja mal fragen, so 300 Euro ist so der Richtwert für die BTS plus halt irgendwie 300 Euro irgendwie die Einsteckkarte für den Rechner, PCI. Und dann ist man so bei 600 Euro, das schon sehr billig ist und kann dann schon anfangen mit der Software, die ja gratis ist, sein eigenes GSM Netz zu starten.
Bevor wir da hinkommen, was wir damit machen, würde ich euch gerne eine ganz praktische Frage weiterreichen. Und zwar von Aline.
Ja genau, hallo. Und zwar ist mir das schon ein paar Mal passiert, dass ich aufgelegt habe, also mit meinem Mobiltelefon telefoniert habe und danach hat es, als ich mich aufgelegt habe, hat es ganz hoch gefiept. Also ich kann es gar nicht nachmachen. Also wirklich sehr hoch.
Denn Telefon.
Genau und das waren irgendwie so komische Geräusche, die ich so von meinem Telefon nicht kenne. Und da wollte ich mal fragen, ob ihr wisst, woher das kommt oder ob es vielleicht abgehört wird oder ob man das überhaupt erkennen könnte, wenn es abgehört wird oder so.
Also das klingt nach Telefon kaputt.
Ja, eindeutig das ist. Also wenn du abgehört wirst, merkst du in der Regel nichts davon. Und wenn du was merkst, weil zum Beispiel mehrere Geheimdienste dich gleichzeitig abhören und die Anlage nicht darauf ausgelegt ist, dann passieren dann so Sachen wie das Verbindung abbrechen oder du Leute dran hast, mit denen du gar nicht reden wolltest. Aber so ein Piepen nach dem Auflegen klingt nach Defekten. Telefon wegwerfen, neues kaufen.
Schön, dass es manchmal so einfach ist. Da hört keiner mit. Viel Spaß mit deinem Telefon. Vielleicht doch mal ein neues kaufen. Was ich auch noch sagen wollte, was gar nicht mit dem Thema zu tun hat, aber mit dem Chaos Computer Club ist, dass noch 383 Leute fehlen für die Netzsperren-Petition dagegen. Und es gibt Stimmen hier im Studio und im Chat, die sagen, das muss doch bis 23.55 Uhr zu schaffen sein.
Genau, klickt doch mal ein bisschen schneller.
Die fehlen an den 100.000 und die Petition läuft auch nur noch sehr sehr kurze Zeit. Wie viel genau, bis eins?
Die Petition läuft noch bis 16. Juni, oder?
16. Juni? Es läuft noch länger.
Es geht um den symbolischen Wert. Eigentlich wollte man diese 100.000 für heute Formattag fertig kriegen, wo es eine offizielle Anhörung im Bundestag gab. Juni. Und wir wollen das wahrscheinlich heute noch schaffen. Dann könnte man dann auf die 150 gehen. Und ich weiß nicht, was das nächste Ziel dann ist. Also falls ihr zu einem historischen Moment mithelfen wollt, jetzt eine gute Idee. ePetitionenBundestag.de Wobei ich ja auch gehört habe, dass der gar nicht sicher sein soll als Server. Na gut, andere Geschichte. Wir sind gerade bei GSM.
Sie hatten vorhin zwar verabtät.
GSM, da hab ich auch gleich noch einen Disclaimer. Selbstverständlich probieren wir solche Sachen nur mit einer drahtgebundenen Verbindung aus und funken nicht etwa illegal durch die Gegend.
Feridelscher Käfig.
Es ist ja denn, wir haben gerade eine Lizenz zum Beispiel auf den Veranstaltungen. Das ist so, dass wir uns, um so was auszuprobieren, also halt mit so einer Basisstation zu funken, braucht man eine Testlizenz von der Regulierungsbehörde. Die holen wir uns halt für unsere Veranstaltungen. Die bekommt man auch, wenn man sagt, okay, wir haben hier halt unsere...
Ist sowas teurer?
Kostet so 180 Euro für 30 Tage in dem Dreh.
Ja, also ist halt durchaus bezahlbar für so eine Veranstaltung. Kein Problem.
Okay, aber wichtige Informationen sagen, wenn ich jetzt sage, geil, das will ich auch, gehe ich nicht hin, kaufe mir so ein Ding und fange an, sondern...
Genau, also du brauchst eine Testlizenz oder also was halt geht, aber...
Das Zimmer mit Kupfer trapezieren.
Genau. Oder du hast halt einen Stahlbetonkeller, aus dem ohnehin kein Signal rausdringt. Also wichtig ist halt, dass du alles unternimmst, dass niemand gestört wird und das Netz auch nicht gestört wird. Also ist dann halt, also ist halt auch kein Schatz so.
Die verstehen da auch keinen Spaß.
Was passiert dann?
Na die kommen halt. Also die kommen dich dann halt jagen.
Und bei GSM Netzen, also erstens die Operator sehen es, wenn ihre Netze gestört werden. Das heißt, wenn du auf einer Frequenz sendest, wo irgendjemand anders sendet, dann gibt es da halt Probleme und das merken die und zwar sofort. Und dann können sie auch messen und sehen, dass dann ein Träger ist, der nicht hingehört und dann fährt ein Messwagen von der Rektie vorbei. Und da ja auch Notrufe abgesetzt werden über das GSM Netzwerk, ist es also ein Eingriff in eine kritische Infrastruktur und kein Spaß.
Das heißt auch vor allem, wenn man jetzt irgendwie ein GSM Netz offen hat und da geht der Nachbar mit seinem Handy rein und versucht da irgendwie einen Notruf abzusetzen, weil seine Bude brennt, wäre es ja nicht anzuraten, das zu tun.
Okay, es gibt also einige Sicherheitsverkehrungen, die man beachten müsste.
Dringend. Aber, wenn man die beachtet, ist es viel Spaß.
Das heißt, okay jetzt irgendwie auf Veranstaltungen, gerade wenn so technisch interessierte Leute zusammen sind, dass man da gerne dran rumbastelt, kann ich verstehen. Aber glaubt ihr, dass es irgendwie in absehbarer Zeit einen praktischen Nutzen hat, also im Sinne von, dass es irgendwie Sinn macht, sich sowas zuzulegen?
Naja, also es ist halt natürlich erstmal ein Forschungsprojekt. Man will halt diese Technologie verstehen, gucken, was man damit noch so anfangen kann. Und es ist halt so, dass diese Idee, dass das Funknetz jetzt nicht mehr zwingend nur von den großen Anbietern betrieben wird, die Kraft sind mehr oder weniger um sich. Es gibt halt zum Beispiel in Asien eine Menge Anbieter, die liefern mit ihren WLAN-Routern, also die du halt so an deinen DSL bekommst. Da ist dann halt auch plötzlich eine UMTS-Basisstation drin, damit die in den Hochhaus-Siedlungen und so, wo sie halt sonst Schwierigkeiten haben, so viel Deckung, also so viel Kanäle einfach bereitzustellen für so ein ganzes Hochhaus, dann benutzen die halt einfach den DSL-Anschluss zu Hause. Das hat in deinem WLAN-Router noch eine kleine Mobilfunkstation drin und die vermittelt wiederum die Anrufe ins Netz.
Das heißt, es ist auch gleichzeitig eine Lastverteilung für das große Netz. Also man hat viele kleine Zugangspunkte und somit verteilt sich natürlich auch die Last in general.
Genau, das Stichwort dafür ist Pico-Zellen und auch Nano-Zellen oder auch Femto-Zellen. Das sind halt so die Stichworte, nach denen man dann mal suchen kann, wenn einen das interessiert. Und de facto ist halt das, was man mit den eigenen Base-Tations macht, das ist auch so, man nimmt extrem geringe Sendelleistung, um halt möglichst keine Störung, um Netzwerk zu machen und achtet halt darauf, dass man halt das Netz nicht stört.
Wobei man sagen muss, die GSM-Basestation, die wir jetzt gerade haben, kann man nicht so mit Nano-Zellen vergleichen. Das ist dann so 50 Kilo schwer und wird scheiße.
Aber hat trotzdem halt nur 30 mW seine Leistung und es wird da geschaltet, ist so. Also Nano bezieht sich auf die Ausbreitung des Netzes. Auf die Ausbreitung des Netzes, die du machst, nicht auf die Zelle. Eine andere Variante, die auch noch sehr vielversprechend ist, ist das Projekt OpenBTS. Da geht es halt darum, auf der Basis einer freien Hardware, das sogenannten GNU Radio oder auch das USRP, Universal Software Radio Peripheral. Also kann man mal nach Google oder Wikipedia gucken.
Es ist nicht gut, wenn es keinen komplizierten Namen hat.
Es ist nur eine vierbuchstabige Abkürzung. Sie ist fast sprechend. Immerhin ein Vokal dabei. Und damit kann man halt auch, es ist halt de facto ein Stück Hardware, wo man in Software Funk machen kann. Das ist total toll, weil man kann, muss halt nicht mehr löten und da irgendwie komische Filter ranbauen und Oszilloskopen messen und diese ganzen schwierigen Dinge tun. Sondern man steckt einfach so ein Stück Hardware in den Computer und dann kommt da Funk rein und raus. So, das kann man sich einfach so vorstellen, so wie man Audio digitalisiert und rein und raus macht, kann man mit so einem USRP Funk rein und raus machen. Und damit kann man natürlich, wenn man die entsprechende Software baut, auch eine GSM-Funkstation machen. Das ist halt dieses Projekt OpenBTS, das ist halt ein bisschen weniger bekannt, als das, was Harald da macht, aber funktioniert mittlerweile auch. Damit wurde zum Beispiel auf dem Burning Man in Ameland, das ist halt so ein großes Hippie-Festival da irgendwo in der Wüste.
Wo alle nackt rumlaufen, Drogen nehmen und zum Schluss eine große Holzfüge verbrannt wird.
Genau, präzise Beschreibung. Die wollen natürlich da auch telefonieren. Und was die gemacht haben, da gibt es halt kein Mobiltelefonnetz, die haben halt einfach eins dahin gebaut. Für so eine Sache ist natürlich auch total super. Die haben halt mit diesem OpenBTS-System an vier Stellen auf dem Gelände halt eine so Bestie schon hingebaut und Zelte so mit irgendwie Kabel über den Acker geschmissen und haben halt Telefon für die Hippies da in der Wüste gemacht.
Telefone für Hippies gibt es schon oder kann es schon geben, weil man da rum basteln kann. Die umgedrehte Frage, wenn eine Technik so weit gekommen ist, dass man damit spielen kann, ist, wie sicher ist das eigentlich?
Ja, naja, also GSM ist halt nicht besonders sicher. Also man kann halt GSM schon abhören.
Ich glaube, es war in der Wikipedia, steht zu der Verschlüsselung bei GSM, was total toll ist. Da stand, dass ein sicherer Algorithmus vorgeschlagen wurde, aber dann doch der Entwurf der Franzosen genommen wurde. Also das mag einen Eindruck des Problems geben. Das ist sicher gemeint, aber nicht zu sicher. So dass die anderen nicht mithören können, aber wir.
Okay, das heißt beim Polizeifunk, wo wir die Sendung angefangen haben, ist es ja so, da kann jeder, also bei dem analogen Alten mithören, der sich einfach das passende Gerät holt, was die Frequenzen hören kann. Das ging ja wohl sogar mit so einem Mickey Mouse Radio, was irgendwann in der kleinen bunten Zeitung mit dabei lag. Wie schwierig ist es bei GSM?
Na ja, du brauchst halt so ein USAP, also so eine Software Radio. Du brauchst die entsprechende Software und du brauchst zum Dekrypten, also das bisschen Verschlüsselung, was da drauf ist. Zur entschlüsseln brauchen wir halt noch einen Stapel spezielle Chips und eine große Tabelle. Also man geht davon aus, dass man es halt so mit irgendwie einem Aufwand von vielleicht 5.000, 6.000 Euro in Nicht-Echtzeit mithören kann.
Nicht-Echtzeit heißt du würdest mitschneiden und dann hinterher sozusagen gucken, was da gelaufen ist.
Da gibt es halt ein Projekt, das heißt airprobe.org, wo diese Softwareentwicklung läuft. Es wird halt noch ein bisschen dauern. Da gab es ein paar Rückschläge, die halt irgendwie damit durchbedingt waren, dass natürlich Leute da draußen auch nicht unbedingt wollen, dass man ein GSM so einfach mithören kann.
Komisch.
Ja, überraschend. Aber am Ende würde es halt den Weg als Vergänglichen gehen, dieses GSM. Wir können halt davon ausgehen, die Bedarfträger, also der Staat kann immer mithören bei solchen Sachen. Aber wir können davon ausgehen, dass GSM über kurz oder lang auch in den Bereich des Amateurabhörens gehen wird. Genau den Weg, den auch ein anderes Verfahren, ein Digital-Funkverfahren gegangen ist, nämlich DECT. Da können wir nochmal drüber reden. DECT ist nämlich das Schnurrlust-Telefon. Habt ihr bestimmt auch alle zu Hause diese Schnurrlust-Telefone, mit denen man halt auch in der Badewanne telefonieren kann oder auf dem Balkon und so weiter und so fort. Da kann Andreas vielleicht noch ein bisschen was dazu erzählen zu dem DECT-Projekt.
Ja, das ist im Prinzip die selbe Situation wie bei dem Polizeifunk, aber nur schon vor zehn Jahren irgendwann wurde halt der analogisch Schnurrlust-Telefon-Service abgeschaltet und dann gab es DECT und dann hieß es DECT ist digital und deswegen nicht abhörbar. War so erstmal nicht richtig, weil irgendwie nur weil es digital ist, kann man es trotzdem dekodieren. Das geht auch mit so einem USRP sehr schön. Allerdings geht es auch noch besser mit einem anderen Projekt. Und es gab eine Gruppe von auch ZZ-Leuten aus Darmstadt, die sich da zusammengetan haben und die für eine DECT-Karte, die man in den Rechner stecken kann, eine Software entwickelt haben, um es mitzuschneiden und wo dann auch die Verschlüsselung mal angegangen wurde und Chips aufgeschliffen wurden, um sich die Verschlüsselung anzugucken. Und auch bei DECT ist die Verschlüsselung nicht allzu gut. Das sind 64 Bit und ich glaube sie sind noch nicht ganz fertig mit dem Krypto-Knacken-Projekt. Also es ist noch nicht so, dass man sich es runterlagen kann, auf den Knopf drücken, was man aber schon machen kann, ist es einzuschalten und zu gucken, wie viele Nachbarn denn so ein DECT-Gerät haben und wie viele davon tatsächlich nicht verschlüsselt telefonieren. Die gibt es nämlich auch.
Das wollte ich gerade sagen, im Anfang, als es rauskam, das war irgendwie zum letzten Chaos-Kongress, da war ja die Rede irgendwie von 50 Prozent, später hat mal jemand gesagt 80 Prozent senden unverschlüsselt.
Also eher 80 Prozent. Und die Leute wissen es halt nicht. Also auch häufig können auch die Hersteller es nicht mehr präzise beantworten, ob sie jetzt Verschlüsselung anhaben oder nicht. Man muss sich das auch mal so vorstellen, so ein Decktelefon kostet halt, also das billigste, was ich bisher gesehen habe, 14, 95. Und zwar ist das der Preis im Laden. Wenn man jetzt bedenkt, dass der Endpreis im Laden in der Regel so etwa bei zwei Drittel Aufpreis gegenüber dem Herstellerpreis in China liegt, dann heißt es, wenn sie da irgendwie 10 Cent sparen können bei der Herstellung, dann sparen sie die halt. So und genau das haben sie halt getan. Die haben halt einfach diese Krüpto-Funktionalitäten schlicht eingespart und gesagt, Herr Gott, wer soll das schon abhören? Was kann schon passieren? Und haben halt genau diese Verschlüsselung einfach eingespart. Und daraus resultiert halt, dass also diese, ja, diese Schnurrlusttelefone, die halt mal eben eingeführt wurden, damit man sie eben nicht abhören kann. Also früher gab es halt diese analogen Schnurrlusttelefone. Die konnte man sehr trivial abhören, also einfach mit einem normalen Funkempfänger. Und die gibt es immer noch längst nicht mehr so häufig. Und bedeckt war jetzt halt die Frage halt so, naja, es ist wesentlich digital, also sollte es halt irgendwie sicher sein. Und das ist nun mittlerweile halt auch vorbei. Also wenn halt dann die Verschlüsselung nicht an ist, dann kann man es halt abhören mit irgendeinem Gehöhe für so eine Einsteckkarte oder mit so einem Gnu Radio bzw. USRP. Und wenn die Verschlüsselung an ist, dann ist vielleicht noch ein Jahr oder zwei sicher, ob es halt auch diese Verschlüsselung gebrochen ist, weil die halt eben nicht besonders hochkarätig zu sein scheint, soweit ich es verstanden habe.
Das ist ja mit dem Abhören dieser Sachen ist ja so, es gibt irgendwie das Projekt heißt Detected Org. Detected, genau. Und diese Hardware, die dafür verwendet wird, das ist ja einfach eine Einsteckkarte für Laptops.
So PCMCA ist das. Also letztlich auf Ebay, damals wo das Projekt aus dem Boden gestampft wurde, für 30 Euro oder so kaufen, mittlerweile teurer geworden, so um die 200 Euro. Wobei hier nochmal der Disclaimer, die Software ist relativ einfach zu benutzen, die Karte auch. Ist genau das gleiche mit GSM. Wenn man seinen Nachbarn beim Telefonieren zuhört, ist das höchst höchst höchst strafbar.
Aber es geht halt sehr einfach. Geht das nur dieser einen bestimmten Hardware, die ja irgendwie veraltet ist und deswegen jetzt auch so teuer, weil sie einfach nicht mehr produziert wird? Oder wird da auch an weiteren Dingen gearbeitet?
Es gibt da auch diese USRP-Lösung, also die komplette Softwarelösung. Das USRP ist so, dass er in Anführungszeichen Wunderteil mit dem man alles empfangen kann. Eierlegende Wollmilch.
Schweizer Taschenmesser.
Vom Kurzwellenfunk über analog 70 cm. Ich glaube sowas wie 700 Euro. Kennten wir es denn davon ab, welche Frontend-Module man reinsteckt, also auf welchen Frequenzen man zuhören möchte?
Das heißt aber, wir sind noch nicht bei einem Level wie WEP, WLAN-Verschlüsselung, wo man sich einfach mal hinsetzt und das macht, wenn man Bock drauf hat. Sondern es ist schon noch mit Aufwand verbunden, das zu machen. Zumindest einem kleinen Finanziellen.
Einem kleinen Finanziellen.
Kleiner Finanzieller.
Es ist aber andererseits so, dass wenn man zum Beispiel ein mittelständisches Unternehmen ist oder eine Anwaltskanzlei, dass man dann eigentlich besser nicht mehr über Deck telefonieren sollte.
Man ist sich absolut sicher, dass die Verschlüsselung an ist.
Selbst da würde ich nicht drauf tippen, je nachdem was man so für Kunden hat.
Genau, wenn man halt irgendwie Kunden hat, die ein bisschen größeres Budget haben, bzw. die nicht so sehr Freunde von Kunden, die man hat, die ein großes Budget haben, dann empfiehlt es sich auch nicht. Also im Wesentlichen kann man sagen, diese Schnurrlostechnologien sind momentan nicht zu empfehlen. Also auch ein anderes Ding sind zum Beispiel drahtlose Keyboards, das ist auch sehr beliebt. Schnurrlostestaturen, die sind halt auch abhörbar. Die kann man halt auch mitschneiden.
Jetzt ohne Probleme oder auch mit?
Ja, ohne Probleme.
Das Schönste was ich jetzt gehört habe ist, wo wir gerade dabei sind, haben Wissenschaftler aus Stuttgart rausgefunden, dass man Nadeldrucker abhören kann?
Und zwar akustisch. Akustisch, genau. Ja, das war schon eine Weile bekannt, dass das funktioniert. Die haben es jetzt noch mal ein bisschen schöner ausgeführt. Und es hat natürlich auch Implikationen für ein anderes, unser Lieblingsthema, nämlich die Wahlcomputer. Weil da natürlich der Hersteller dieser NEDAP-Wahlcomputer möchte gerne da so eine Nadeldrucker nachrüsten. Er hat wohl Grüne gewählt.
Ich meine, wenn man damit Musik machen kann, dann...
Also das fängt völlig vom Thema ab, aber was solls, ist ja eh gleich vorbei. Der Nachteil bei den Wahlcomputern war, dass man nicht nachweisen kann, was da drin passiert. Deswegen sollte ein sogenannter Paper Trail eingeführt werden. Also die sollten ein Zettelchen ausdrucken, wo drauf steht, was derjenige gewählt hat, was derjenige dann in die Hand kriegen kann. Und das soll dann per Nadeldrucker gemacht werden.
Genau, das ist halt so einer der Pläne, die da momentan kursieren. Aber das ist halt ziemlich ja Unsinn. Und wir gehen mal davon aus, dass es auch irgendwann wieder beerdigt werden wird. Wenn nicht, müssen wir es halt nochmal zeigen, dass es kaputt ist.
Das hat ja schon mal ganz gut geklappt.
Das machen wir gerne.
Wie, haben wir beim Digitalfunk jetzt noch irgendwas vergessen? Also ich fürchte mich eigentlich diese Frage zu stellen, weil wir noch wenige Minuten haben.
Wir haben glaube ich irgendwie nicht geredet über digitalen Kurzwellenfunk. Wir haben nicht geredet über DVB. Doch, DVB-T haben wir mal.
Da hatte ich doch am Anfang die Frage, ob es da so Basteleien gibt, wie man deinen Empfang verbessern kann?
Antennen, also bessere Antenne, so wie früher.
Also so ein bisschen mit dem Standort spielen, irgendwie gucken, dass man vielleicht eine Aktivantenne benutzt, mit einem besseren Gewinn dann auch und ans Fenster, solche Sachen.
Das wollte ich fragen. Ich hab es ein paar Mal schon probiert, diese ganzen USB-Sticks, die man sich da in den Rechner steckt, die haben immer einen grottigen Empfang. Und dann liest man im Kleingedruckten des Geräts, ja es könnte sein, dass man sich eine Aktivantenne dazukaufen muss. Das ist eigentlich eher noch Standard, oder?
Ich glaube schon. Also was dieses Digitalfernsehen eingeführt hat, das muss man vielleicht mal erzählen für all die Leute, die Panik vor Elektrosmog haben. Früher so ein Fernsehsender, der hat gerne mal mit 1 Kilowatt gesendet. Und so ein moderner Digitalfernsehsender, der sendet dann mit sowas wie 50 bis 100 Watt. Das heißt, allein dadurch, dass das analoge Fernsehen in Deutschland abgeschaltet wurde, ist die Elektrosmog Belastung auf den Viertel zurückgegangen.
Aber die Pulse!
Was?
Pulse?
Genau, digital, also digital pulsiert doch immer so. Und das ist natürlich ganz schlecht.
So, dann würde ich vorschlagen, wir gucken jetzt noch mal, wie viele Unterzeichner es gibt. Im Chat hieß es dann auch so, das ist doch gar nicht die offizielle Zahl. Aber es ist halt die einzige, die ich habe, die von der Seite.
Ich sag nochmal ein tolles Wort, was hier auf dem Zettel steht, was wir nicht mehr erklären werden. Quadratur Amplituden Modulation.
Okay, wenn wir schon so weit sind, ja, dann machen wir doch das hier.
Das ist einfach, das ist fünf Tonnen, da gibt es einfach irgendwie.
Ja, das wird verwendet, um sozusagen auf dem aktuellen Bossfunk Steuerinformationen zu übertragen. Also zum Beispiel Einsatzfahrzeug teilt Leitstelle mit, dass es jetzt gerade mit den Einsatz übernommen hat zum Beispiel.
Ist dieses Signal schon ein Code für ein bestimmtes Ereignis?
Dieses Signal ist schon vorher festgelegt, ein Code für ein bestimmtes Ereignis meistens. Da gibt es irgendwie bei den meist umgerüsteten Analogfunk in den Polizeiautos dann auf dem Handhörerknöpfchen, womit man dann auswählen kann, irgendwie einen Einsatzleiter habe, Einsatz übernommen.
Aber es ist doch so, wie ich heute über euch gelernt habe, dass Analogfunk der Funk ist, wo man quasi einfach mitmachen kann, wenn man nur die richtige Frequenz erwischt.
Das ist durchaus richtig.
Das heißt, wenn man sich so eine Signale abfängt und dann mal schön in das Netz, also in den Ether pustet.
Dann tut man illegale Dinge.
Ja, deutlich illegale Dinge. Man muss sagen, wir werden deutlich weniger Spaß haben mit dem Zuhören am nächsten 1. Mai, aber vielleicht ist es doch besser, dass sie auf digital umsteigen.
Ja, also hier wird gerade noch angemerkt, die 5-Ton-Folgen sind tatsächlich zum Alarmieren, also um halt z.B. Sirenen auszulösen, ähnliche Dinge. Die Status-Meldung ist der FMS Telegram, das Funk-Meldesystem. Das ist halt so ein Prrrz, das halt vor dem Funk-Spruch und wenn man dieses Prrrz dekodiert bekommt, dann kriegt er eine Kiste Mate.
Eine Kiste, wow. Apropos dekodiert, es gab ja vorhin eine Morse-Folge zu hören. Ich habe noch per Chat den Hinweis bekommen, Chaosradio ist zu 50% richtig, würde ich sagen.
Genau.
Wollen wir es auflösen, weil jetzt ist die Sendung gleich vorbei.
Kriegt ihr eine halbe Mate?
Eine halbe ausgetrunken.
Okay, der zweite Tipp wäre gewesen, Chaosradio Digitalfunk.
Ja, das ist korrekt.
Damit herzlichen Glückwunsch an Ravox, der glaube ich entweder selber geraten oder im Chat gut abgeguckt hat.
Der kriegt von mir auch eine volle Mate.
Einzulösen nächsten Donnerstag in den Clubräumen des Chaos Computer Club Berlin.
Das war es Chaos Radio für heute. Es waren nicht viele Leute dabei, aber wir konnten viel lernen über Digitalfunk. Nächsten Monat um diese Zeit erwartet euch wie gewohnt der Kollege Jakob Kranz und neue Gäste vom Chaos Computer Club. Ich wünsche euch noch einen schönen Abend. Vielen Dank Andreas, Björn und Frank, dass ihr hier wart. Famous Last Words. Und spielt schön am Gerät. Und zum Abschluss gibt es noch ein Song aus dem Netz, den es einfach da frei runter zu laden gibt und zwar von Trackey Birthday. Website. Ein sehr schönes Beispiel wie Nerdcore. Ach, das vergessen. Und als nächstes nach dem Nerdcore kommen Smith & Smart und irgendwie 100.000 andere Leute in Studio, machen euch einen Nightflight, der wirklich cool wird. Also er muss wirklich cool werden, weil die Jungs machen am 29.5. eine Konichi Bar Bitches Party. Ich hab vergessen wo, aber Maxwell, der vorm Studio steht und total böse guckt, wird euch das bestimmt gleich noch 5000 mal sagen. Auf jeden Fall jetzt im Casio Paya hör ich da gerade. Konichi Bar Bitches Party mit Casio Paya, in der Casio Paya am 29.5. mit den Leuten, die gleich hier ins Radio kommen. Jetzt geh ich aber wirklich genug geredet.
Vorsicht vor den Pulsen.
Ruhe im Saal oder ich lass den Saal räumen. Angeklagter, hier wird vorgeworfen, Musik illegal aus dem Internet heruntergeladen zu haben. Was sagen Sie dazu?
Ich hab sie doch gleich wieder hochgeladen. Und das wird man.